this is Jocko podcast number 180 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening it was
May 1968 we were triple volunteers we
had volunteered and graduated from the
Army's parachute jump school at Fort
Benning Georgia made it through the
qualification course at the Special
Forces training group in Fort Bragg
North Carolina and after attending the
5th Special Forces Group airborne
in-country training program we had
volunteered to serve in Mac V SOGs
command and control during Special
Forces training at Fort Bragg several of
the Green Berets teaching various
courses told us to avoid sea and sea
because the duty was rough and the
Special Forces casualties were high in
the top-secret unit
despite all those warnings Rick Howard
John McIntyre Rick Estes Tony her L mark
Gentry Bob Garcia Bobby D leathers
myself and a few others volunteered to
serve in C&C I'd been in training or in
between training cycles since entering
the army
on 1 December 1966 in May 1968 we were
finally shifting gears from being in a
training mode to an operational mode
none of the rumors prepared us for what
followed you won't need those the
sergeant major said put away all pens
pencils and notebooks this is a
top-secret briefing all of you have
either obtained a top-secret clearance
or will do so in the near future or you
wouldn't be here welcome to the command
and control detachment of the 5th
Special Forces Group airborne 1st
Special Forces United States Army
Special Operations augmentation study
and observations group or simply C&C
gentlemen before you is a
confidentiality agreement you can't tell
your girlfriend your mother no one
we were prohibited from writing anything
about the operation forbidden from
keeping Diaries taking photos making
drawings or tape recordings notes of any
sort the sergeant major advised us that
anyone who didn't want to sign that
agreement could leave gentlemen the
sergeant major turned toward a generic
map on the wall the North Vietnamese
Army controls these neutral countries
and pointed to Cambodia and Laos located
to the west of the Republic of South
Vietnam and of course North Vietnam for
several years the North Vietnamese Army
had moved soldiers supplies Rockets guns
and propagandists south into the eastern
provinces of neutral laos and cambodia
through an ever-increasing network of
trails and roads called the Ho Chi Minh
Trail complex now listen up real close
the sergeant major said when you go
across the fence you will carry no
identification of any manner shape or
form that meant no identification papers
no dog tags no Diaries no photos no love
letters and certainly no Green Berets
everyone would wear sterile fatigues
with no company insignia no name tags no
unit designators no jump wings or Combat
Infantryman badge --is why without
giving anyone a chance to respond he
said that because Laos and Cambodia were
neutral the United States government
could publicly proclaim that the u.s.
representing thus if we were killed in
Laos Cambodia or North Vietnam the US
government would deny having anything to
do with us the United States government
would explain that no Americans were
stationed in Laos or Cambodia which was
technically accurate the US government
had a plausible deniability if we were
killed or captured and if captured we
were to speak a foreign language
don't tell them who you are he ordered
remember technically under the terms and
conditions of the Geneva Accords your
status is different than Air Force and
Navy pilots shot
North Vietnam there in uniform there
identify Laz a US servicemen CNC men
don't fall into the category of
prisoners of war we were in effect spies
although the sergeant major never used
that ward he also didn't tell us that
spies had no protection under the Geneva
Convention and that we could Summerlee
be executed you have captured and that
right there that's some excerpts from
the beginning of a book called across
the fence which is written by a Special
Forces soldier in Vietnam named John
Stryker Myer and in this particular case
it is an absolute honor for me to say
that we have him here with us tonight to
teach us about his experiences as a
member of Mack V SOG studies and
observations command group command and
control teams sir welcome welcome to the
show glad to be here that's plane to
welcome you got there Vietnam huh yes it
was quite something absolutely good at
the time we just watched the John Wayne
movie to Green Berets on top of it all
so we were all psyched we've seen the
movie we're ready that's all it takes
and we've been forewarned you know when
you go there this is gonna happen the
little guys gonna come out and ask for
people to volunteer so we said yeah
right now when we were done it happened
before they shipped us out a little guy
comes out we're looking for volunteers
and then Johnny Mack goes for what Sarge
I can't tell you either you're in or
you're not so we raise their hands next
day we're up and denying for that
briefing you covered
how before he could jump into that yeah
how do you how did you end up in the
military would you grow up you grew up
in Jersey yeah crewel be Trenton New
Jersey dad was a milkman we opened a
milk truck and the mom was the piano
teacher choir organist and after high
school it took me two years to flunk out
College upon flunking out in 1966 I was
working up to Yosemite National Park
nurse yeah as a garbage man firing man
up there and the book the Green Berets
came out and my dad has sent me a letter
saying hey that's it you finally flunked
out you're going to get drafted
we got the notification here from the
draft board so I read the book and I
said you know what if I'm going to go if
I can get in with these guys that would
be a great challenge of them if I can do
that
that's the way I want to go because at
that time with the army of eight weeks
of basic training eight weeks of
advanced infantry a month leaving here
in Vietnam you could be with any regular
conventional unit and by that's how
there have been enough stories about
some issues particularly when they were
engaged in a regular North feed in Bihar
me that Dara have some major issues
surprises at how strong the enemy was so
give me some more training I needed it
and what when you were a kid where you
did you play sports or anything like
that yeah I was never that good at it
but I loved baseball as a head game and
football and my dad wouldn't let me play
football till my senior year of high
school so I had one year of football but
everything else was just like JV Little
League just love baseball more anymore
you played football didn't want to get
hit in the head too much you know what I
think it was more well in eighth grade I
hurt my knee playing soccer I said they
were worried about follow-up injuries
here and still have your body and Pete
want peace when you go to college or
wherever you gonna go no so they were
very conservative mean you know my mom
she's no farm girl from Central Jersey
and she wouldn't she was really unhappy
when my granddad gave me a cap pistol so
that's the household we grew up in but
you know eventually we we went out
learned about weapons a little bit along
the way and then of course when this
came along do we got the real deal and
the what was so 1966 so public opinion
wasn't completely against the war yet
was it in 66 no but it was beginning
you're starting it was starting you you
had people doing their protest
and letters to the editor and some of
the fringe elements to society like you
see today some of those parallels but
you going down how did your parents is
you your dad was on board obviously
because he sent you the letter saying
alright buddy yeah well at school did
you flunk out of tritons State College
yeah and then you just said I'm gonna
have grown to Yosemite to be a
firefighter well we had a couple of
buddies of mine that I've been in
college with helped me flunk out and we
did much much serious drinking just the
you know just stupid young young a dumb
and the idea what you're talking about
yeah I thought sure and so they had a
corrupt congressman that got us jobs in
Yosemite so it's a good old Frank
Thompson came through for us we drove
across and in fact the in Manhattan
Kansas we got hit with tornado June 12th
going across the Rocky Mountains we had
snow with the back window blown out of
the car and so it was just fun yeah a
nice experience again we drank a little
bit too much there but first time a real
job real money and then the reality
check there's just like these guys are
amazing if I mean if I can get even
close to this to get the jump school at
least get a taste of this so that was
the plan how was the how was the culture
shock when you rolled into army boot
camp well about that time I seen you
know a couple dozen of the movies over
time from the world war two movie so he
kind of knew what was coming so early on
I had a a friend of mine whose dad had
been in the Army he goes look you go in
just remember this is like a game they
want to see if they can break you or not
and you just gotta have the right
mindset and that's stuck with me so if
you Basie particularly jump school they
come in and shake you out a bit two
o'clock in the morning for bogus
inspections just to see if they could
mess you up or break you a little bit
it's kind of like okay we all notices a
game we're all no we're training here
and so that was the way we move forward
and you guys could go right into the you
got you could go right into the q course
like you could just do that pipeline it
was open for you
well because we lost so many people they
came out but at that time we called the
baby
sf course so yes and even to this day
some of the guys that went through
training group with are still down a
brag now training SF guys and I mean
we're biased but we feel that if you
come through basic advanced jump school
and go right into the Q course and
qualified now I have a pre qualification
than your qualification and then you get
to pray that there's no bad habits
mm-hmm like a lot of the sergeant's from
the old days when they came in you you
had to be an e5 above more more time in
grade etcetera etcetera and before
they'd be even consider you but they
needed bodies well the guys again we're
biased so then we get the bias out front
as the green kids that came in that went
off and did the job and eventually at
SOG by 68 69 the majority of the 1 zeros
team leaders were young guys and there's
a lot of us that either got bored like
in my case flunked out or just wanted
some different something different and
said this is Special Forces and then you
get the rumors and then you finally get
to that briefing where you say he has a
chance to volunteer little do you
realize there's the highest casually
operation an entire war yeah they forgot
to tell you they didn't tell you that
part
so did you did you volunteer for C&C
while you were still stateside or was
that once you got overseas no at that
time the only way you get into Special
Forces or that program was to enlist for
airborne on assigned and then when you
went through basic then at advanced
infantry you you would be offered the
opportunity to volunteer so during one
of the classes they would have you know
like in my case it was a rainy day we're
in the gym there's like 678 people
sitting on the floor and it had the
stage up front which side steps and a
cook would come up to say hey the
coolest MOS you'll never go hungry with
us and they're all fat and sloppy you
know
traditional cooks and then other gods
coming for kamo Intel MPs that kind of
stuff at the very end this little banty
rooster comes in and it was raining so
everybody else had arranged a kid stuff
on this bandy rooster comes in with a
beret and his fatigues are wet he came
up and did a straight jump on the stage
turned around and said we're looking for
recruits for Special Forces if you if
you're interested see me outside fact
anybody interested well hell I read the
book I jumped up off the floor me about
three other guys and the other 700 just
sat down I'm gone like WTF have you guys
are gonna Nam in a couple weeks I'm
gonna give just a little bit more
training here it was just amazing so he
jumped off the stage that's it so he
banished through psychological tests had
to show we could swim run all that stuff
and when you a calm guy initially did
you get trained as a calm guy yes is it
what do they still call a teen echo back
then or no notice
this is pre historic gun 5b 4s the 4s is
the SF designator God and oh five B is
comma Morse code and then an through
training group we've sent they sent us
down for 12 weeks to Fort Gordon for our
TT because they need a lotta a camps and
course C&C needed some our TT operators
radio teletype and so that was the extra
training and that's where I got busted
me and Johnny McIntyre got busted down
to private educe so we landed a non word
you would use would you do too or not
well we were just assholes really I mean
these are these are butter bars two
young lieutenants there's company and
Here Come these Green Berets we just got
done all our training yeah we're
official Queen beretta you're the
baddest man on the planet here with your
buddy
so when I have my Oracle fifteen hearing
with the co I go in and there's eight
article 15s on the Toa says pick one if
I've picked once crust it up and threw
it out because you got nine now I got me
a maggot I got busted so easy deuce
landed in Nam Zandi deuce yeah so you
get two so it was until you got to
Vietnam correct that you heard about CNC
or no you said some training instructors
right
Cromwell well you know here one of these
little sidebars and we go through kamo
myself
McIntyre and a few of us got recycled
because you had to get up - I forget 12
or 15 group word Anderson Thurman yeah
wpms yeah I had to it the that I feel
team I went through a course like when
the last guys that were learning Morse
code and we had to get whatever it was I
think we had a lower standard than that
cuz we because it was just no one would
you want even officer them give you the
officer out so no but one of our guys
who took us under his wing was a guy
named Paul Villa Rosa
SFC been and on three times had a little
tattoo around his neck cut here and but
he helped us he got us gone so in our
mind he and we had Wagner and Rousseau
two other instructors for the oh five B
and so one day got to know is near the
end it's like hey you guys go
don't do this volunteer stuff get an aid
camp learn about the people blah blah
blah okay that's what it came down to so
when we get that briefing the top-secret
briefing and one of the first things we
hear about from scuttlebutt Paul Villa
Rosa was ki a the first ki a out of fo
before at the time which was in January
of 68 so here's one of our living
legends who got us in the SF trained us
up as ki a and that has you know talk
about psyops it hit hard but you but so
that was in Vietnam would mate for when
they now said to you okay yeah do you
want to be a part of this other program
right do you want to go one more
volunteer get out and then up here yes
sir of course you're like yeah let's
bring it let's go young and dumb and
then so then so then you immediately got
assigned they said test to screen you
anything any anything else or they just
said oh cool you're you know smart
enough to volunteer yeah you thought of
Vettii had been done and all of us
either had the top secret or it was in
process and so from there literally the
next day a plane to Danang up north and
then we had the briefing and and of
course you know we had a safe house of
denying where does
there's house 22s or a safe house and
welcome to Special Forces you know and
that was a safe house that was run by
either us or the agency or both and you
know you go in and here's old SF guys in
fact it was one of the teams just got
back from trying to rescue one of our
hatchet forces and there is a sinner
talk about the combat and macron are
sitting there going oh shit we're gonna
really die mm it's a good thing we spent
our money could we when we were going
through the RTT training we had a
weekend pass we go up we're in
Washington when we see the Tet Offensive
and the tanks are running over Liang V
the a camp in lying to a 101 there we go
we we know we're going to die with high
degree of certainty so we went home took
our money out of the bank all of our
princely earnings of $1,000 we hate
steak dinners until he went to Vietnam
so there we were at this house 22 and
we're thinking about the same thing as
guy oh shit we're really into it now and
so we go upstairs take showers and in
the showers a couple of these hookers
that are in there
dujun out with the coke coca-cola yeah
and they're cleaning up just like
welcoming you here a couple guys getting
a load in the back there and they're all
pumping away it's like oh this is really
cool it does put this side of Vietnam
here we go yeah so bring it on we're
ready and then and then you talk about
that flight up to the first place you
got a sign worse it was fob one f1z one
yeah sorry we we was called an f OB or
you guys call a fob generation I guess I
guess we're cutting corners over here
okay so you're gonna fov one call it
anything you like you leave the supper
well there's a whole there's a whole
there's a whole offshoot of the word f
OB which we turned into fob have you
ever heard the term fob it before yes
yeah so someone that stays on the fob
and never goes out yeah yeah so known as
it rents yeah well yes the ramps is what
you guys called them and I don't know if
you did the name of my consulting
company is national on front and the
reason we called the company Ashla on
front is because we wanted people know
that
were the guys that were like in the
front and if I not not picking out the
ramps we just specifically take it from
David Act where it's book indeed read
YES on a ton a ton of times yeah me too
how is it yeah awesome and flying up
into fo b1 right with the king bee yeah
how was that oh god it's just another
day of the secret war you know because
they had the old age 34 and so the
pilots sit up high and then you had the
the apartment and the back for the
passengers and as a door gunner
so when mcintyre me and John Hutchins
give on the H 34 is the doors only on
the right side so we all get in and I
see the helicopter pilot gonca I mean
the gun are gone was the gunner
Vietnamese yeah this is all Vietnamese
were you were you ready for that
mentally not at all okay just like yeah
because is not really important note to
make to everyone so that the the
aircraft is being flown by a Vietnamese
pilot with a Vietnamese copilot and a
Vietnamese gunner yeah it was the two
19th Special Operations Squadron for the
South Vietnamese Air Force and all
pilots and so you know our training was
we're gonna work with the people there
the indigenous people but when you
literally climb it to their helicopter
and your life is now in their hands
that's like you know we did I made you
Mesnick I didn't really think about it
much but it was its taking those couple
steps jumping in and going like WTF -
what's going on here now I thought we'd
have you know lady Huey like we've seen
in the movie with John Wayne they all
had you it's none of this old 834
Sikorsky thing you know and that has
that in the engine then that was a b-17
rotary engine and we're gonna get into
the factors now those guys proved
themselves over and over over again to
be just incredibly brave and not not
just incredibly good pilots but just
brave beyond comprehension when you were
flying up there was it was it a mellow
flight up there was full yeah there's a
great beautiful day
you know it's warm like it you saw is
hot but once you get air you get to flow
you know how it is we were
on through and we going over to
cemeteries and everything that we're
going down Highway 1 which is heading
north from Danang up to Phu Bai and we
went past the food by airport and so
we're flying north when the west side of
the highway 1 and you see the airport
and then this big compound which was the
2nd Armored Division training cramp
company and then all of a sudden it's
like you're flying north and then you're
on your side looking straight down at
the real you did a 90 degree flip as
begins his turn so I seen the guy
talking the door gunner like doing a
scrunchy thing you know could we all had
our new fatigues and you could just tell
we're newbies disgusting new butts green
ass Green Berets man this guy's gonna
have his kick so I was kind of thinking
something's going to happen well this is
it
well Mack at Target was Jesus and
Hutchins goes the same way and I watch
the guy so we did the you know you look
down there's the road and it's the first
time we had a helicopter with that kind
of a radical ride and so he did a 180
then came back and did a 360 and landed
we get off well we get off and then a
recon team gets on disappears was that
was that spike Team Idaho that got all
right okay so so that was one zero as to
bracelet right there and that does that
you got off that bird that brought you
into fo b1 yeah and it was despite team
Idaho that got on board yep then Lane
was the one zero and Robert Owen was the
one one with four indigenous troops were
five indigenous troops and and so you
start your check-in and whatever and
then whatever however many hours goes by
yeah and all of a sudden what's
happening on camp when you start to
realize that something's gone sideways
well you know I was very fortunate when
with the training group I was a catcher
and played center field for a company
softball team and we went on to feed at
that summer and the reason why spider
Parks Robert J spider Parks was our
pitcher and that little skinny-ass Texan
could bring and we still played fast
paced not a Wimpy slope is shit
and so we want our games and so I come
in we land McIntyre and iron Hutchins
and we're like literally walking in
front of the s3 office just it had a
long road that went from highway 1 east
into the compound the training centers
on the right it's all new we here to
Vietnamese and we hear Cambodians on the
left if you go down and we get in and
take our stuff out we're just standing
looking stupid and then here comes
spider parks and it's like whoa am I
glad to see you could we use it we were
both in a company together spent many
months there training up before we came
and now he but he was the one that told
you what was going on with no cause
right at that point it was like hey you
know I got a spear bunk if he goes in
toss the sergeant majors as I noticed
asshole I'm gonna bring him in with me
for a couple days and we'll see what's
going to happening because at that point
spider had been on Idaho run four or
five missions with sergeant lane and
then Lane said you're ready for your own
team so he promotes him off they appoint
him as a-10 and so he was in that
interim time waiting for the transition
to come where he's going to get assigned
a team and so he's in base team goes out
so he's got a high degree of interest
and what what their statuses so they
missed the first column we'll check they
gave a team okay which in our case once
you're on the ground you usually wait
about 10 minutes to see what's going on
around you gave a team okay then the
assets leave because they can't stay
that long anyway at least the
helicopters do they head back which the
team okay was breaking squelch on the
radio right generally generally speaking
yeah and for those either don't know
what that is when you brakes we squeeze
the handset on the radio it you can tell
on the other end okay they just
purposefully squeeze that microphone
three times we know that that's the
signal for okay right and sometimes
early on that guys may say team okay but
yeah
later on I saw was just break break and
then they say okay then Covey would
leave so they were in and then spider
came back later he goes hey we haven't
heard from Idaho so by dinnertime hey we
haven't heard by head oho
haven't heard from them we're really
concerned about what's going on here and
then bought it morning there's still at
that point not a word when at what point
did you guys get word I know I I'm hazy
on how many what the day or time frame
was but eventually another they decided
that has been too long no comma they put
in with the call bright light which is a
team that goes into either finding of
the team if there's casualties or down
piles that's what the bright light
missions were down pilots bringing
relief or just bring casualties out or
help people get the team out the wounded
team so they went in a team that went in
everybody was wounded one guy was killed
this is from the team that went in went
in for the bright light this is this is
an Oregon correct yeah with Mike Tucker
and and George the troll Sternberg they
went in and at one point they were
thrown here they were in a bomb crater
and so the NVA were hitting them with
our weapons car fifteen fire they had
our m26 frag grenades one of which blew
off george's jungle boot so all these
guys really banged up pretty bad when
they came out anybody got out and they
did but they didn't find anybody from
Idaho
correct I'm gonna take it back to the
book here this is sort of the this is
this is the reaction back at fo be one
when Oregon comes back
back at base there was a collective sigh
of relief that st oregon had survived
the short-lived but furious but
ferocious bright light mission the loss
of st idaho however hung over the camp
like an invisible fog spider was the
first person I spoke to after that
bright light he went straight to the bar
unable to believe that st idaho had
vanished the complete lack of clues
added to the mystery where they killed
when they wounded captured and now
prisoners of the NVA mcintyre voiced
everyone's next thought before he be
captured by the NVA he said he'd kill
himself with a round from his car
fifteen or pretend to be dead and blow
as many NVA as possible with one final
hand grenade there was no doubt in my
mind I'd never be taken alive
from that day forward I always carried
an m26 frag grenade on the upper hook of
my web gear it was the last one I'd used
I would use
welcome to C&C McIntyre muttered we had
heard about st ASP from fo before
vanishing and Laos presumed ki a on 28
March 1968
but there were others sergeant first
class Robert L Taylor killed for April
st bear from fo b3 k IA Laos major
George Cuomo u-17 crash died 14 April fo
b5 based spike team members sergeant
first class Leroy and right and staff
sergeant Lloyd F mu sow ki a fishhook
area of Cambodia to May fo b2 based
lieutenant Joseph C Shrieve ki a hatchet
force operation one may fo b1 based st
Alabama team members specialist fifth
class Kenneth M cryin and private first
class Paul Chester King kaa a shalt
target form a fo b1 hatchet Force
sergeant first class Ronald J Miller ki
a 12 may ever be one based Master
Sergeant Robert de play-doh and first
and sergeant first class John Hartley
Robertson kaa King be helicopter Crouch
crash Laos 20 may additionally 5 SF
troops were killed at fought fo b 3 from
mortar and artillery shrapnel between 15
and 21 april 1968 specialist 5th class
Charles M quarry specialist 5th class
Daniel F Sandoval sergeant Dennis Thorpe
sergeant 1st class
Stefan Maz AK and specialist 5th class
Samuel are Hugh's McIntyre and I didn't
personally
Avik a haze but the sheer number in that
short period of time was sobering most
of them were veteran Special Forces
soldiers being as green as we were made
us all the more nervous but not scared
enough to quit C&C that's uh that's
that's quite the quite the welcome
aboard oh yeah and then do a one little
side note on spider parks on that bright
light when the team came out they were
so shot up because one of the team
members got additionally wounded on the
extraction that they never gave a team
okay spider went down with a king be
separate King bee got out looking to
make sure everybody was out and he took
they took a tents fire that king bee got
fired up and on extraction the door
gunner was koat on that so spider was
quite a mess when he got back yeah
that's that was such a short period of
time to be losing all those guys that's
a matter of months oh yeah
and we left several out so these are
these spike teams going in explore you
explain a little bit about what the
spike teams were what are consisted of
the spike teams was a code name for our
Recon teams they had two basic elements
with CNC the hatchet forest which could
be a company Pitou noir company size
operation and then the Recon teams which
we had would be two or three Americans
with the corresponding number of
indigenous troops so initially we ran
three Americans with three South
Vietnamese and the South Vietnamese on
our team were really good and then later
they were so good I just ran myself in a
1-1 with for a ditch and we trained up
heavily particularly up to that and then
learn who the best ones were we had a
couple of guys that had been like hep
our interpreter Sal who had been there
they've been running missions for over
two years by 68 so they were highly
respected in fact only about a grace of
God they weren't on a team that
disappeared because we were able to
build around them you have this other
part in the book here this is another
sort of welcome to fo b1 during the
during the first few weeks in fo b1 I
attended at least three memorial
services for fallen sf comrades services
were held in the mess hall the last one
I attended was for Lane and Owens during
the service the chaplain hesitated
Elaine's name this was the last official
function honoring spike team Idaho's
members and the chaplain couldn't
remember lanes name I didn't care if he
had attended two dozen memorial services
for other branches of the military that
day I was so angry I never attended
another memorial service at fo b1 the
services soon stopped anyway because
there were so many casualties no
official announcement they just stopped
yeah you and I were talking a little bit
about Ramadi when we were in Ramadi and
the you know one thing that we started
doing immediately was going to the
memorial services of the soldiers and
Marines that were getting killed and
that was a big wake-up call for
everybody I I can tell you I don't think
probably anyone in my task unit had ever
been to a yeah I had ever been to a
memorial service overseas for guys that
have been killed I mean and here we were
there what they were happening every day
you never think about it now until you
there no and you guys weren't having so
many casualties that they just said okay
well we're not gonna have them anymore
here's talking about some of your first
few operations that you went on and I
don't think I've talked about this but
so these little teams that you had yeah
these little teams were getting into
helicopters and flying over the fence
which means over the border into Laos
and Cambodia to do reconnaissance pretty
much in the middle of nowhere by
yourselves correct this type of
operation in present day is not very
likely to happen the mountain risk that
you guys were taken it's it's crazy to
read about like my my personal
contingency that I'm running through my
head you know what if this happened what
it what if that happens right I'm
looking at these saying yeah if I was
the commander in charge I'd say well you
need to come up with a better plan you
need come up with something where we
have better backup
especially when the situation is because
you guys can get air support and you
guys used it heavily boy yeah as soon as
the weather rolled in it was like you
guys are out there on your own and I
mean we'll get into some stories we got
your home for sure and you know and as
that that element of is the next series
contingency we had no artillery no
traditional army or Marine Corps support
that and of course no SEAL Teams
yeah they were busy doing her stuff on
the coast and so it was quite something
go across the fence and in a way we were
flying into the 18th century because
everything was so old the way of working
and they said do slash and burn
agriculture so you come in with the
helicopter everybody we hear you coming
and the local people had to cooperate
with the NVA or because their model was
work with us we're gonna kill your dumb
ass so the game was on and the purpose
of most of these was to figure out where
the trails were what was being
transported what where the location of
enemy person
were it was bait it was your basic
reconnaissance missions right well in
addition to yes that was the first part
so you always had general missions he's
a point mission because by the end of 68
they were building fuel lines from the
north they were coming down they were
going across the DMZ River in layoffs
and so we heard reports about that so
that could be a point mission or a
general recon see where the movements
gone what the supplies are and then
wiretap peel W snatch and those were the
other missions and so our our South
Vietnamese were trained we trained them
up so back then we had stayed ERT
cassette player right and South could
climb up a telephone pole hook it up and
it covered a wire all the way up with
mud so if anybody walked past they would
never see that wire and we would record
because the CIA told us if you record
even though you don't hear anything keep
it on because we get this taste back to
us we're gonna amplify it a hundred
times because the North Vietnamese
phones even though we're in the cradle
they were still on and we could record
it data amplifying that you hear people
talk to the background get into off of
that so those are some of the other
missions so you start going on your
first few operations here and by the
next morning back to the book by the
next morning the weather had broken - we
were inserted smack dab in the middle of
the biggest road running north to south
through the A Shau Valley am I saying
that right SL a Shaw Valley there was no
jungle there were however hundreds of
bomb craters of various sizes but what
surprised me the most was the number of
punji pit that we passed some were huge
large enough for animals and you go
through this mission is one of your
first missions and there's like no enemy
contact and when the guy through with
walking and I looked at each other in
complete disbelief we just walked down
into the valley of the shadow of death
without seeing one NVA soldier spider
joked with me saying that I was one of
the few people in the history of CNC to
have a run a practice mission and two
missions and still have not gotten the
combat infantryman's badge the award
given to soldiers who had seen combat
with the enemy or were under direct
hostile fire I kept telling myself but
this was a fluke and I remembered what
the special forces trainers told us at
Fort Bragg the NVA and the Vietcong
guerrillas will fight when they want to
know sooner so your first couple of
operations you got pretty uh pretty
lucky oh yeah we're Slater's house not
ruin it because we've put in those air
force sensors and then we had all this
year's tacky air stacked up
could we just figured it's gonna be a
shit show mm-hmm nothing happened so we
left out some pork so pour in the v8
gunner opens up with a 50 caliber if
they killed him several times man and
they pom bombs because they want to use
something on this big mystery were you
uh the other interesting that you talk
about in the book I don't think it was
one of yours but there was even when you
guys would do training missions over
there that was like a potential for
enemy contact on your training missions
absolutely yeah Lin black and his team
they ran a heavy contact in fact it was
the Navy that saved her dumb ass all
that one training mission could they
just happen to have the frequency the
Kinky's couldn't get in and they called
the Navy and they came in a big boat
yeah yeah some kind of that's really
one's own but he came in and pulled her
ass out could they
the Vietcong had mustered a couple
hundred people are coming after and they
were just out trying to do like a
shakeout patrol just a little training
operation yeah just a little in-country
thing you know it's just go train get a
couple days get out of camp eat some eat
some lips have some fun well your uh
your luck didn't hold up yes going back
to the book and is this guy's name south
am I saying that right
perfect okay bye now sow eyes were solid
eyes were bigger than saucers so you've
been inserted and now you you're
starting to have a situation unfold if
you raise spider Walken said tell him
I'm declaring prairie fire emergency if
he says anything about not hearing any
gunshots tell him to fuck off I'll
explain later
Sal's never been wrong look at him as we
spoke Sal looked at us beaucoup VC
beaucoup VC called King B's now he
whispered and then you get on the horn I
have a prairie fire emergency team
de-stress I have a prairie fire
emergency can anyone hear me
I spoke in a hushed tone with my hand
cupped over the mouth of the radio I
looked at my watch we still had more
than a hundred minutes before our next
scheduled combo check with Spyder at
1600 no one responded so the the deal
with comm windows are back in the day
when we had batteries that would run out
you couldn't just sit there and monitor
the radio all the time on either side
people that were waiting for you to call
they'd be waiting and they didn't want
to they wouldn't monitor the whole time
so they would come up at certain pre
designated communication windows so
that's what's going on here
you have this bad situation unfolding
and you go to call but they're not
particularly listening it at that moment
which is why no one's responding right
yeah I'm just explaining that to some
folks that because nowadays we have well
first of all we have cell phones what we
call anyone whatever you want it makes a
nice ringtone and you talk to whoever
you want there even when I got in we had
calm windows oh that right yeah yeah
well yeah we setup cause a comrade -
sure yeah setup calm windows and we'll
call you you know whatever it was every
two hours or whatever and that's the
situation that's unfolding right here
you guys still hadn't been contacted yet
so back to the book I sat down with my
back against the PRC 25 and opened a can
of apricots I was facing south and just
starting to sip the sweet apricot nectar
when all hell broke loose the green
jungle around us erupted with deafening
full automatic blast from NVA ak-47s and
our car 15s because my back was to them
I hadn't seen Sal's warning gestures or
watched him get the jump on the
approaching NVA I remember spilling
apricot nectar on the stock of my corn
15 as I turned to my left with a
majority of the NVA gunfire was coming
from foolishly my first thoughts were
that I have to clean off the nectar off
my weapon
and not spill the entire can of Africa
apricots because I had waited so damn
long to eat them they were always a
treat in the jungle but the initial
seconds of the firefight I remember Sal
and how do I say is an infant what a
fuck
fuck fuck yelling pro-family profanities
at the envier as they fired on
full-automatic the crack of a que 47
rounds and and never sounded louder or
closer all I could see from our
perimeter was Gunsmoke the red and
orange blast coming from the darker than
ever green jungle and the green ak-47
tracers flying over our heads in an odd
sort of way there was an eerie Beauty to
the scene the thunderous fury of dozens
of men blasting away at each other on
full automatic within 10 feet of each
other
killed all other sounds the eardrums
were numb adrenaline had slammed into
our blood streams and was now screaming
through our systems it heightened all
senses it extended time for example a
car 15 fires 20 rounds of 556 I've lost
the ammunition in less than one and a
half seconds yet those first opening
moments of combat with the NVA seemed
much longer than a half a second then in
a second and a half ordinarily when
firing on full automatic the weapon
expended rounds quickly and we trained
ourselves to try and gauge when that
last round and the magazine was slamming
into the receiver some men placed a
trace around in the magazine as a visual
cue during that firefight it seemed as
though I counted the rounds leaving the
car 15 and knew exactly when the 18th
and last round was exiting the weapon
also during that first expand exchange
folk was slightly behind me to my right
and since I was on the ground he was
firing over my shoulder that exposed my
right ear to almost a full blast from
his car 15 the explosions were painful
but fuck saved my life
I had aimed the car 15 down the hill
toward the largest number of ak-47
muzzle flashes that I could see to my
left what I hadn't seen were a handful
of a handful of NVA soldiers who broke
out of the jungle to the right and had
opened fire on us folk realized I hadn't
seen the NVA troops coming up the hill
so he got to my right and blasted them
back into the jungle I was so focused on
the first muzzle flashes that I
completely missed the others if those
NVA soldiers had advanced a few more
feet we would have been history and the
remainder of the team which was on my
left would have been at risk that
time-warp continued when everybody ran
out of bullets simultaneously the only
audible the only sounds audible were the
metal clicks of cold magazines being
slammed in the
machine guns and bolts slamming shut to
resume the firefight a key element in
any firefight is the race to reload
after the initial contact on 7 october
1968 st idaho won the race
no one was faster than sow heap hep hep
folk at getting the first magazine out
the second one in and returning full
automatic gunfire on the enemy within
seconds we had gained fire superiority
the months and months of training on the
range under the tutelage of Spiner
spider and walkin all of the live-fire
drills all the live fire races to see
who finished reloading first paid off
all other games in life were frivolous
and irrelevant in this deadly game if
you missed hitting the target you died
that was your first big contact huh that
was it that's a doozy
it was absolutely and it still sticks
with us you know you never forget it
that fuck I mean later on we're back in
base I was complaining glad I didn't
realize what had happened and so talking
through HAP the interpreter said you
dumb fucker I just saved your ass these
guys were coming up the hill and you're
too stupid to realize it oh so you were
mad at him for shooting too close to air
because my ear is fuck I couldn't hear
for the days it's like so thanks for
saving my life on complainer classic oh
yeah you continued on with us a little
bit as as we gained complete fire
superiority I turned on the URC ten
beeper and started screaming into the
PRC 25 I have a fucking prairie fire
emergency that bitter fear laced plea
was greeted with complete silence woken
was less than subtle keep yelling until
you get someone a key factor in St
Idaho's favor that day was the small
Knoll that woke and has driven us to the
jungle is so thick and the knoll is so
small that only a score of NVA could
rush at once they weren't moved they
weren't fast-moving fear-inspiring
charges that the NVA were known for
successfully executing either here the
jungle worked against them but the NVA
kept coming at one point walkin pulled
me over pointed into the jungle and said
look they're stacking up dead bodies to
get to us
hips showed me can you believe it and
they keep coming hell if we kill enough
of them the body stack will be as high
as we are because the jungle area was so
dark at first I couldn't tell exactly
what I was looking at but walking was
right the NVA were stacking bodies and
firing at us from behind their dead
comrades a lot of NVA soldiers died in
those first few minutes of hell on earth
that's a determined enemy oh yeah and we
heard about you know it's one thing to
hear about it basic and and Special
Forces training how determined the enemy
was and to see it firsthand
dying like that I mean Lily just kept
coming and we had high ground you know
thank God for high ground thick jungle
and the fact that it wasn't a big big
area where they could mass more do you
guys didn't bring up you guys didn't
have an automatic weapon with you he
doesn't have an a double I Cal I had
like a belt-fed machine gun you guys
wouldn't carry those no we had a sick
well dick a six-man team and the team
son of teens began carrying the m60 a
little later and then the RPG because
they cut the bear off and I had the the
magazine of the circular magazine the
hills I think it's 250 rounds and God
but they would someone did it but in our
case because we carried the m79 also to
solve offense 39 or that gave you a lot
extra firepower but did you use the
foolish at rounds with that or just the
desert a chi but the first round would
be flesh yet uh-huh so if anything was
close that would be the first round and
that we need a cheese we had a chi rails
but no a double used man that's it this
I when I hear that story right there I
would do anything to have an m60 machine
oh yeah absolutely
yeah but just the weight the rounds and
everything else you know like in my case
I carried the radio always a character
radio yeah and so between the radio the
battery and we always had 600 plus
rounds we were um we I was on my first
deployment to Iraq I was I'm like one of
my first controls in Humvees and we were
out and we we ended up we hit a little I
don't know what you call them a steel
Hedgehog do you know what that is yeah
it's like a little obstacle right right
that Americans had put out Americans had
put it out a steel Hedgehog a little
it's like a little obstacle for those
you don't know
it's to prevent cars from going by well
we were we we made a wrong turn
somewhere
and we went down the road we weren't
supposed to go to and we hit one of
those little steel and chalks we didn't
know what it was so we're driving along
is actually my Humvee too and it it made
a loud noise and sparked and I actually
thought in my mind I thought we just got
hit with a low order ie D like a low
order booby booby trap that didn't fully
explode so we come to a stop and we all
get out of the vehicles and now we're in
the middle of Baghdad and we're just
surrounded by threats and in our mind
we're about to be attacked because we
didn't know that we just ran over our
own American thing but we're - so you
don't know we don't know that so
everyone's out there we're off there
with our with our m4s our little
basically car 15 yeah and you know like
I fell I think I felt completely naked
saying myself God you know like we need
better weapons now we had 50 cals
mounted in the Humvees but you know once
we were mobile I'm thinking we do why
don't we have when we have you know
belt-fed machine guns when I got when we
got back that night it wasn't just me
that felt like cuz that because that
night all my guys they went in every
Humvee everyone put belt-fed machine
guns we mounted them we staged them so
anytime we got out of those vehicles
with yeah we were ready to go to war oh
yeah yeah but in the situation like that
because you can have all limits that
people coming up you have a bill nuts
but you have that naked feeling yeah cuz
in aw in a situation like this it'd be
nice going back to the book more than an
hour my cries and screams in the radio
and the you are c10 beeper went
unanswered as the NVA
more attacks there was no need for radio
secure procedures now the hide-and-seek
portion of the game was over now it was
simply a matter of survival my respect
for the NBA's tenacity grew that day but
the hill the jungle in our car 15s
worked against them as they continued to
pile up or drag away more bodies with no
help around conserving ammo while
keeping the enemy back became a top
priority there were no more full
automatic blasts from us although we had
been in contact less than two hours it
felt like we've been fighting for
several as the team anxiously awaited
for help from above the few team members
pitted against the enemy NVA seemed
ludicrous in terms of survival the
enormity of the jungle hit home yes sir
you got how many rounds did you say you
would bring well he always carried 600
plus per man Oh No the Vietnamese would
carry a lighter load because they could
because there's only one lake 98 pounds
uh-huh so I forget what they're looting
and you guys had 20-round magazines at
this point right correct no 30 were just
a dream we thought about and a couple
guys were smart enough to write to call
order and they had a mail to him later
we weren't that smart we had the 20
rounds but because of the spring you
only put 18 yeah
and so you're taken at some point
probably half longing to this are you
starting to take point shots instead of
oh yeah you just wait till things come
out you see it and then just one two
finally I heard the Texas drawl of
spider on the radio an f4 phantom jet
returning from a bombing run in northern
Laos had heard the beeper and called him
I told spider we had a Perry fryer
prairie fire emergency spider said that
he had also called the judge and the
executioner who was the judge in the
executioner they were pilots for the
176th out of Americal division and they
were two muskets okay and they had been
assigned permanently to C&C earlier in a
year and they built the camp duck and
then they had been assigned own camp
duck was closed down food day came to
foo by an ass he built a barracks that
the
the podcast and they were one of the
crews them and the Marine Corps a
Scarface were gunships that regularly
hung out with us saved our bacon so the
the judge he they had these old gunships
that could barely get off the ground but
he had the rocket pods and then the
executioner was a cook and he had the
minigun those are some awesome call
signs oh yeah going back to the book
thankfully we had made mirror contact
with Spyder earlier and he was able to
pinpoint our location in a matter of
minutes soon Spyder was over us he told
me to pop smoke our SOP was not to say
what color smoke grenade we would use
assuming the NVA were monitoring our FM
frequency I popped a yellow smoke he
said he saw two yellows which meant the
NVA were monitoring our frequency and in
guessed which color we would use we
changed frequencies and I popped a
violet smoke a few minutes later the
first a1e sky Raider arrived on target
and made a gun run on our eastern
perimeter his wingman made the first
napalm run on the south side put your
heads down I'm gonna make you sweat he
said he brought it so close we could
feel the heat from the deadly jelly a
few seconds later we smelled burning
flesh he dived toward us a third time
the pilot drawed it's crispy critter
time the napalm run was so close we
could feel the air being sucked away
from us by the exploding material if the
jelly had landed on a person's skin it
would continue to burn either until it
burned itself out or was deprived of air
by mud or some other substance thus pads
arrival changed the tempo of the
firefight when the NVA heard the old
World War 2 plane making another run
they charged us in in a desperate
attempt to get as close as they could in
order to avoid the sky Raiders deadly
ordnance the N word NVA were getting
close to the belt that's horrifying
so hell's that don't understand the
tactics of that situation you got
aircraft overhead they're dropping
napalm so one of the V you think oh cool
that'll make the NVA run away no no
actually what they want to do is get
close enough to Americans that they
can't get napalm dropped on them by 68
they had to tack it down really tight
they knew when the aircraft was there
that they were safer - closer to us and
then so they get closer hoping to wipe
us out and to save their own ass that's
like there's I guess there's no higher
motivation than that napalm coming at
you if you stay where you're at
nasty and so therefore even at that
stage of the game we had to go back to
full automatic a couple times because
they're charging hard oh yeah what
numbers are we talking about
no never knew we just stacked them up so
high we'd never had you know no time to
go do a body count you know how that is
you're just busy killing yeah I don't
want to throw that out this all
nonchalant like yeah I know how that is
no actually we never stacked up bodies
so high that we lost count going back to
the book then an Air Force pilot an f4
phantom arrived on station tell your
people the ordinance will arrive on
target before you hear me or the rounds
the pilot said I told the team to put
their heads down the phenomenon of
having bullets tearing into a target
before anyone could hear the aircraft
which delivered them was unbelievable
the jungle in front of us was shredded
by the f-4s gun run within a minute or
two his wingmen dropped two 500-pound
bombs the change in aircraft staggered
the NVA for a few moments right then and
there I thank the Lord for Uncle Sam's
air force the judge and the executioner
rolled in right behind the fast mover
the judges minigun was real close to our
perimeter seconds later the executioner
followed behind him firing several 2.75
millimeter rockets well as door Gunners
blasted away with their m60 machine guns
because we hadn't expended any ordnance
to our West we ran the gunships over the
western edge of our perimeter they drew
no enemy fire either about a half an
hour before dusk spider told us that
King bees were on their way by that time
the judge and the executioner had
refueled reloaded and were returning a
few minutes in front of them
everyone in ST Idaho was dangerously low
on ambien ammo grenades and m79 rounds
so now you got the the extract platforms
are coming back the King bees are coming
to get you
before the King bees moved in an attempt
to pick us up spider had the judge in
the executioner make gun runs so close
to our perimeter that we could hear the
expended shell casings from the gunships
and 60 and mini guns falling to earth
through all the excitement I told walk
in and that spider had spotted an area
west of our perimeter where king bee
might be able to settle into some
elephant grass for us walking in and hip
passed the word to the team and we
started moving toward the area from our
location we couldn't see the elephant
grass and I had assumed we were locked
into double or triple canopy jungle
again the judge and executioner hammered
our eastern flank as we moved toward the
tentative LZ so I got a sore eye if you
could explain spiders position a little
bit because that's pretty I think it's
pretty unique to Vietnam of how those
guys could be up overhead sort of
watching and and directing ya there
we called in copy the code name was
Covey seal vui but they would afford air
controllers basically and in in the C&C
mission you have an Air Force pilot at
that time most of the copies were Oh too
says no to that push pull double engine
and but the Wizards have a prior one
zero somebody with experience who've
been on the ground who would be with the
Air Force pilot so the pilot would fly
then he would turn the radios over so to
spider or whoever the copy writer once
but that was a slot so sometimes the
guys would be wounded they couldn't go
to the field but they could fly Cuffy
got it so that when we're on the ground
we have a situation that we're dealing
with then he's able to understand as
opposed to talking to an Air Force pilot
who's just used to getting a bomb and
drop it somewhere and talk about a
contingent liabilities that spin off of
a firefight and so that was a spider
shop he was the cubby Rider and he and
Pat walk is that they were the two cubby
riders that came in and they covered us
until they got us out
going back to the book sound hip were
covered our frantic desperate drive to
the chopper
after taking 10 minutes to cover those
last 10 yards we reached the hovering
king bee which is about eight feet above
the ground fox set up an impromptu
security watch on the western side of
the rotor wash a quick check of my
ammunition revealed I was down to one
frag grenade one white phosphorus
grenade and two magazines of car 15
rounds if I didn't get extracted that
last frag grenade would be mine there
was no way in hell I was going to be a
powa after all the NVA ST Idaho and TAC
air had killed if I had to use it I take
as many NVA with me as I could
that's a bold statement oh yeah but I
just
by that time we knew about peeled of is
what they go on through and we had lost
a couple guys and one of them had
escaped and they were you know we're by
now we're hearing the POWs stories right
so I was bad nothing country but for our
mission no was it going to happen I
figured if this is it I was trying to
take as many as we can make it a final
contact check now you guys eventually
get to where you're loading the the King
beasts which again these are Vietnamese
pilots they're old
aircrafts I probably look like they were
held together with duct tape but he
always had oil and fluids inside and so
tau if you sat in too deep you get the
fluid on your head but we liked him
better than the UE because they could
take they could take more hits and they
had those old b-17 engines up front the
nine rotary heads and they could take
more hits that's why we liked him
and this captain Finn is how he say it
up in ten ten at some point during the
craziness I looked up at the pilot of
the King be captain tin he was above all
the madness on the ground completely
calm and collected while his aircraft
took numerous hits from enemy rounds
what made his demeanor all the more
extraordinary was how it contrasted with
our adrenaline hype frantic behavior on
the ground we've been fighting for hours
we were dirty
we were sweaty and we were exhausted and
there sat captain tin cool as a Rocky
Mountain breeze
giving the impression that it was just
another milk run It was as though he
said no sweat boys I got all day you
just take your time the stewardesses
will break out the beverages after
you've secured your seats
looking at captain tin for a brief
moment generated a mental image I'd
carried with me forever frankly I never
understood how one man could be so
steady under so much enemy fire and keep
the chopper hovering can you imagine
Tuesday I can yeah and you could go into
a little bit further here a day or two
after the extraction
captain tin and his crew came in to fo B
ones Green Beret lounge I went in and
thanked him again and ordered a couple
rounds of drink for all the King B
pilots and crew members speaking through
an interpreter captain said the King B
he flew to extract us from echo 4 had 48
holes in it from an enemy ordnance
sitting at the bar captain appeared to
be just as cool and above the fray of
daily life as he had on 7 October tin
said that an enemy round had torn a
baseball-sized hole through one of the
rotor blades I asked him how he could
hover so long he told me that when he
piloted a helicopter he thought only
about flying nothing else no enemy
bullets weather or anything only flying
if it's my turn to die I died that day
wasn't my turn to die amazing man he's a
he lives in Arizona today really he's
still alive yeah Oh we'll be having him
on the podcast hopefully wants to come
on here
that's awesome and then you had one of
your guys and this is a this is like the
other end of spectrum like it's hard to
maintain when your guys Davidson had to
talk to you and he came up and he said
tilt and I haven't mentioned that your
nickname was tilt yet we're gonna get
that nickname pin balls see if you play
a pinball machine you lose and walk away
pissed off when I lose I shake this shit
out I get to see by nicknaming neon
how did the SF guys know about that how
they learned about it from us goes way
back yeah it was a kid we said they're
like pin balls all the time little anger
management issues Oh indeed yeah yeah
so Davidson he comes up tilts I have to
tell you something brother I don't think
I can do this I survived act 2 brother
but I ain't seen I never seen shit like
that before in my life we were really
lucky to survive that mission I don't
think I can go on I hate to desert you
brother but I think I want off the team
now I understood that look on his face
from the previous day
I told Davidson that I respected his
decision and I appreciate his frankness
I thought it took more courage to be
honest in camp than to not say anything
and go in the field a man unsure in the
field could get other team members hurt
he reiterated that he had performed well
under fire and echo for he hadn't run he
hadn't quit and he had demonstrated
exemplary courage during the entire
mission as we walked and talked I put my
hand on the shoulder James you and I and
Walken did something few men in America
will ever do we survived echo 4 and all
the NVA could throw at us there were six
of us against hundreds of North
Vietnamese finest we will have we will
always have a special bond something no
one can ever take away from us thanks
again for your honesty I asked him if he
wanted me to talk to the sergeant major
or did he want to do it because he had
only been in campus Shore a while he
asked me if I wouldn't mind speaking to
the sergeant major first I agreed
and asked him what sort of assignment he
preferred I don't know brother
I'll need some time to get my head
straight and you have a note in here 32
year
three two years later I talked to James
Davidson in New Orleans on the telephone
one of the things he said was brother
I've never been the same since those two
days in Laos oh yeah and he gave me back
the captain tin for a moment the aunt
they pulled us out and we landed Phu by
I'd climb up the bank and say come on
I'll get you a drink
he goes no my family's waiting for me
they're holding dinner no and even on
that extraction that night because it
was right at sunset and so when we
pulled out it's one of those beautiful
scenes where it's a dark green evergreen
of the jungle hmm and all these little
sparkling lights that are red with the
green trace is coming up if it hadn't
been trace it was just a beautiful scene
but then you realize hey that's the end
of EI still trying to shoot our dumb ass
down and it was but then we flew he had
a South directly for a few minutes we
had the sunset it was that sweet sunset
mm-hmm it was at that point that Sal
looked at me and gave me that look this
all was so we cut the mustard so here
you know cuz when I first got any cam he
looked at me when I came into the Spyder
introduced me he goes he's too tall his
feet are too big and he looks stupid it
took me five months to get to get on his
good side but we finally got there an
echo for all you had to do is just fend
off a few hundred NVA together yeah
that's all it took and and so Davidson
so this was a volunteer to get into the
program and you could at any point say
hey you can do it oh yeah absolutely
and no dishonor to it yeah always
preferred because like with Lyn black in
in chapter 6 when they came up against
ten thousand one of his Americans who
was the son of the general who was just
there to try to get some medals for
himself never fired one round anger and
prayed during the entire day with his
face on the ground the Vietnamese were
ready to kill him
so that's kind of thing that you don't
want no no that's that's horrible
yeah these these contacts that you're
getting in I just it's it's hard for me
to get my head around you know how to be
it out there like alone like that with
with just really limited support you
know oh yeah there are days but we had
Uncle Sam's air force and those door
Gunners who are great yeah absolutely
and we had Scarface know from Marine
Corps and we had different units were
attached to us and we're just really
lucky whenever we call it they always
came and the fact with one Scarface oh
it was
Lieutenant Colonel Robinson mm-hmm
he pulled us out several times after he
pulls out the one time he got his
plexiglass shot out the bird shot up we
get us back the freeway chewed my ass
every time we come to get you and he
chewed my ass out we go into the club he
still chewed my ass out
I bought him drinks got so drunk he
couldn't walk he had to fly he's still
too AM ISS a colonel are you saying
you're not gonna come the next time said
I didn't say that every time you rang
the bell they came yeah but oh my god
they could barely don't ever try the
door Gunners we get out to helicopter
they're like B or D models those really
early you II saw this is true of the
muskets the door Gunners have to get out
and kind of lift the helicopter as they
tried to get enough power to get off the
ground because they're just so loaded
with ordnance then they jump in once he
got moving quite a sight but they always
came and the other thing is that's
weirdest they didn't really have
nighttime capability not like anyone so
well I it seems like the liked it
nowadays no tonight is no factor for
America oh I know he would have run over
our mother from one of those nods oh
yeah absolutely yeah but for you guys
once the Sun went down it was hard to
get picked up it was hard to call for
fire it seemed that way oh yeah no doubt
and then you're racing this you were
racing the Sun you will resonate your
voice yes she's a she's a key player
between the weather and the sunset
yeah that's the other scary thing is
you know this is something I usually say
early on but I haven't said yet I'm
reading tiny excerpts of this book so if
you're listening to podcast these are
tiny excerpts this is less than five
less than three percent of this book
this book is filled with this kind of
mayhem so you have to get the book to
appreciate it all I'm just kind of
hitting some of the the highlights but
yeah the fact that you guys were racing
against the Sun going down and how L the
Sun Goes Down okay cool what does that
mean in modern-day SEAL Teams for me
that means we use a night strobe an
infrared strobe that the enemy can't see
instead of a marking panel what does it
mean for you it means nothin another 12
hours out in the bush is you're not
getting picked up you just hope that the
the Lions would leave you alone you know
I mean the Tigers you had this one idea
or you know your your the group had an
idea of dropping like a big giant daisy
cutter'
but a big bomb like a 2,000 pound bomb
right in order in areas that were so
packed with with vegetation that you
couldn't get in a helicopter in there
say oh we got an idea we'll just drop a
big bomb and then let's go land in there
yeah get dropped off in there and so
this this one operation where you're
doing that you're you're heading into
the jungle you're going to one of these
things where you dropped a 2,000 pound
daisy cutter' bomb you're rappelling
you're the number one man heading down
right and you you decide that like hey
this is an abort situation I think you
saw some enemy oh yeah
and so you decide okay let's abort this
thing and here we're going to the book
as I looked up I was glad to see King
who's one of your team members climbing
back into the King B I got on the radio
and told Covey to abort the mission as
we had been compromised again for a few
fleeting moments I'd considered trying
to get the team on the ground frankly I
was sick and tired of getting shot out
of L Z's and I wanted to run a mission
instead of going through the
gut-wrenching firefight on the L Z's
which is you know again I'm skipping
around this book but you would do
mission after mission where you guys
would try and land you get shot off the
LZ oh yeah
um that would be the primary secondary
and then the alternate Elsie's so you
try three insertions you know I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna for the record if I
go one insertion and I get shot off I'm
coming home I'm coming home we source
code I'm not gonna go to the secondary
and if I get shot off the secondary I'm
damn sure not going to the tertiary and
think I'm gonna getting away with it I'm
gonna go back and come up with a new
plan yeah well by then the King be
running out of the gas he had to go back
so you're there then I saw the helmet of
an NVA soldier heading toward the bombed
area he was approaching from the area
where I heard the first voice from the
jungle area in front of the helicopter
which was up the hill from where I was
on the ground as soon as I saw my open
fire with like ar-15 suddenly the king
bee swerved away leaving me on the
ground suddenly it was eerily quiet then
it hit me I was standing in the middle
of a smoking LZ in the middle of Laos
and I was alone all of a sudden I felt
small very small the trees that had
survived the bomb blast were tall the
jungle surrounding the LZ was both
impressive and formidable and not
somewhere I wanted to travel by myself I
tried to raise Covey on the radio there
was no answer from Watkins even though I
was the American team leader on St Idaho
I insisted on carrying the radio because
I wanted to be the person calling
airstrikes around my team the Vietnamese
kept us alive in the field and I felt my
end of surviving the jungle warfare was
to direct tactical air strikes and
helicopter gunships to the enemy so the
king bee comes back so you're there the
king bee comes back captain
two long drops a drops a rope down to
you for you to clip into because it's I
guess too tight for it to land or it
doesn't want to land because it's gonna
take a bunch of time and energy so they
just throw you a rope yeah they can't
land because there are too many tree
stumps the Lazy cutting everything down
and then at that time we were just
refining the tactic of using rope
extractions so a pretty one that's
listening right now when you're refining
tactics try and do it on training
operations
well we did we trained we had 150 foot
rope sandbag to it and then I had a
d-ring on the end and be a hundred fifty
foot rope and so you had to have a
sandbag so we get through the jungle to
get to the ground to you and we hadn't
developed other tactics but you had a
d-ring on your chest well you gonna get
to that yeah yeah but so yeah here we go
I saw no NVA but the weapon that was
being fired at the unmistakable bark for
an ak-47 I fired another m79 round in
that direction that rounds explosion
must have startled captain Tuan because
he jerked the King be upward yanking me
off the ground before I could slip the
d-ring on my left shoulder around the
Rope that shoulder d-ring was critical
for staying in the Swiss seat we had
heard horror stories about the body
desecrations and the the NVA had
performed on SOG men and I didn't want
that happening to me as too long lifted
me into the air I opened fire with my
car 15 on what appeared to be a muzzle
flash coming from the hilltop area so
you're getting hoisted up by the
helicopter while you're returning fire
and slipping out of your Deeping it
didn't quite get hooked in cuz I bet as
we got a little higher up buzz
ricocheting off the trees I was I was a
human pinball for a few minutes air tilt
there we go
then I became scared so then you decide
to become scared okay that's fine I
still hadn't hooked my shoulder d-ring
and someone fired a few green tracers at
us capital Wang started to pull out of
the target area as he started gaining
speed I ricocheted off a few trees
before I cleared the jungle having sat
in the King B's copilot seat I
understood why he pulled away from the
LZ before I had cleared the trees if the
chopper gets shot down the mission turns
into an operational nightmare while
potentially hinging or killing the crew
and the recon team members aboard the
ship I wasn't angry with him hell he
came back from me I would have been
stranded down here for at least two more
hours before other choppers with ropes
could have been able to extract me if he
hadn't but being dragged through the
trees hurt I was angry at myself for not
getting the damn d-ring hooked before I
lifted off the ground my arms were
getting very sore as I went to switch
arms I was struck by some sort of air
pocket and suddenly I was upside down at
five thousand feet
my only physical link to life was the
d-ring hooked into my rope seat and the
150 foot piece of rope hanging from the
helicopter I twisted my body to look up
at King again thank God he was still
hanging out the door i signaled to get
the chopper to land as I was giving King
signs I felt the Rope slipping down my
thighs to my knees at the same time my
web gear was sliding from my hips over
my stomach toward my neck in a matter of
moments the Swiss seat was at my knees
the only way I stopped it from moving
further was by spreading my legs I felt
really stupid after all the training
this was gonna be a dumb way to die as
the Rope slid across my feet I knew I
was moments away from passing out there
was no way I could keep my legs spread
just before the end several brief scenes
from my life flashed through my mind
dolorous my kindergarten sweetheart why
did she move to California I saw my
dad's new 1949 Chevrolet milk truck with
its dark evergreen paint with the white
side panels and rich gold leaf letters
my red wagon from childhood high school
football games and to add insult to
injury I saw the front page article in
my hometown paper about my death the
story was below the fold because stories
about local boys dying in Nam were now
commonplace that angered me because my
family would never know where I really
died on the other hand I didn't want
them to know how I really died just as I
started to pass out I felt the Rope slip
off my feet my body went limp I vaguely
remember hating the elephant grass
before landing hard on my back on the
ground
I had fallen only 10 or 20 feet the
elephant grass cushioned the fall I
hadn't realized that captain Tuan had
the aircraft descending during those
last frantic moments oh yeah had those
legs spread like a New York City hooker
yeah that's uh that's a nightmare yeah
King came out and picked me up and threw
me in the in the chopper left all my
gear there so my car 15 and my sod knife
which now would be a highly treasured
item still only us oh you you lost it oh
yeah he just pulled to open the web gear
and I had to get the thing off my neck
the rucksack the web gear no just choked
me out he pulled it off and just picked
me up and then threw me in the
helicopter I never I was really happy to
feel my head bounce off that metal floor
it hurt but it's a happy hurt yeah oh
yeah yeah again if you have to get this
book because that's I'm trying to pick
like some good stories but these are
just the kind of ridiculous things that
that are going on just another day in
saw just another day in SOG it hung
upside down 5,000 feet above enemy
territory by a d-ring another one here
you guys got some bad weather you're got
no support overhead that's another thing
people need to understand is when you
because of where you guys were located
at a pretty good distance away from the
bases if there was no aircraft overhead
then you wouldn't be able to communicate
with anyone because they would lose line
of sight
did you guys carry ever carry HF radios
to try and make long-distance we had VHF
or UHF yeah there are 10 was that and
but at nights during the day there was a
there was always an airborne command
aircraft up so at the daytime was
Hillsboro code at night it was Moonbeam
so they would check in with us on our
frequency so you would no matter what
you'd have some right of console okay
that's good and so because of the we
knew the NVA
RDF radial direction finder was really
good they were they were sharp on that
so when they would check in with us
again it we just did click click no
discussion and fuzzy they don't know the
that's direct radio direction-finding
so if you sit there and talk on the
radio for a long period of time the
enemy can actually capture those
those transmissions trying to may use
multiple stations and they can tell what
direction they're coming from and they
can triangulate where you're at and they
can come and get you so for this
particular one you guys are the
weather's bad so you don't have any you
don't have any actual direct support
overhead the the NVA have been just the
word that's the one where you got you
try to set up an ambush and they told
you don't do it well we had the ambush
set up we'd been in but then they told
you don't execute the ambush right don't
execute it because we were had visions
of we get the POWs the nut day if he
captured a live PW five-day R&R anywhere
in the world $100 bonus like man we're
talking about where de Plank and plans
Hawaii or Australia we hadn't quite
decided and his spider came back over
and I gave him the code we got a peeled
up he would be back at the primary LZ in
one hour that's what he said don't move
yeah but you hadn't initiated you didn't
have the peeled up no yet you were
waiting oh yeah there walked up and down
a chill yes it was just a matter of time
before you're gonna well be spring your
ambush and this is one of those deals
where we violated all the rules of recon
no need we go ten and ten walk ten
minutes pause tend to hear the jungle
let the jungle
see how it's gone well this one because
we've had so much trouble trying to get
in
they had slash-and-burn areas that were
underneath the jungle canopy I divided
the team we had an eight-man team this
time before on each side and I said
we're gonna go up this hill until we get
to an area to a trail or whatever and we
didn't stop we went really hard maybe 20
30 40 minutes I forget now we came up to
a big trail we crossed it one at a time
covered our tracks got things set up
South put up the wiretap had a perfect
ambush you know we had trained Lynn
Black had developed the the ambush kill
zone so that we have claymores that
would go across but in the center there
be a 6-foot area that to be no shrapnel
but we had he he practiced on himself as
c4 so he finally figured out at this
certain length what a stick of c-4 was
we'd knock yourself out but he did
literally yeah I know
is another yeah so that's our infamous
book yeah but we had it all set up so we
had the c4 to knock out one person
claymores to kill everybody else with
sides perimeters and one in the rear
just in case he came down the mountain
on us and there did he pop and up and
down a trail we could we could have had
officers there walking down the trail
nobody's that upset because we had gone
so far so fast violating all of our
rules that the people up the hill didn't
know what was going on down the hill and
then Spyder says don't move it's like
that's when things got really ugly and
we what was the reason why he told you
guys don't do it because the weather was
moving in oh yeah
we only been on the ground two or three
hours and the weather sock did he's at
10,000 feet I can't even see the
mountain let alone see an LZ so he's
saying look we're not gonna get you out
of there right now
just don't do whatever you gonna do and
oh yeah break contact get away yeah so
you guys are kind of kind of on the run
you guys start moving out of there right
and so about that time up the hill we
hear the tanks and other trucks starting
up their engines and all of a sudden the
activity on the trail goes from casual
to frantic now everybody's two or three
guys they all got through aks would
Ethan clued him in that you were there
while they heard has come in and by then
we could hear the dogs they had some
dogs that were deaf back on the LZ so
they had started looking for us
officially so when you hear dogs tanks
trucks and a bunch of people with ak-47s
yeah how do you feel about that
the pucker factors - zero
it really is it's like oh my god and you
know that you've got no form of
extraction correct the weird thing is I
guess and and having worked in the
jungle a little bit you know I've I
spent some time in the jungle in South
America and in Southeast Asia like I
will say this the jungle is huge right
yeah and you could see where okay I can
get I can make myself scarce at least oh
yeah until you remember they got
trackers right and they got dogs blossom
so you're in that situation here yeah
another Thursday night but we did get
the wiretap though Sal had run karate I
was for an hour so once you want you
guys had to take the tape recorder with
you though oh yeah we carried the little
you know what do you think about a
traditional early old mmm cassette
recorder so I had like two or four the
chip of a D batteries in and then we had
the microphone that had a little
plugging in and this Sal would run up
the tree or fly up the telephone pole in
this case he'd gone up when he came back
down and put mud on the whole thing so
anybody going by on the trail looked at
the pole they wouldn't see it and so we
ran it for over an hour we had run that
wire tab and it flipped cassette over
because that was state of the art at the
time yes that's now you guys are moving
pull back all the clay amoris to see for
which direction did you head did you go
away from where you inserted did you go
back to where you were and some we went
no we went away from it if I'm facing
the LZ we went to our left your honor
and we wouldn't he had to go we across
that big trail again but this time we
had to cross it in between enemy coming
up and down the truck it went past us
and so took us a while to get back
across the big trail to this trail again
this is Laos
yeah by the way this is lighter Chi Minh
Trail the Ho Chi Minh Trail spiders that
even when he could see the jungle
he couldn't see that road and the road
was big enough you could drive tanks
down and side-by-side it's huge
be the equivalent of highway 78 okay or
fifty to two lanes so the tanks side by
side but it's conveniently covered by
covered by the judge to vegetation so
took us a while to get across the road
then we went to the left then we finally
came to a little stream bed and went up
that stream back because now it's dark
but now we hear more dogs the activity
on the trail another couple trucks go by
and all this noise we noted looking and
eventually you're holed up and you're
you you stop right and I'm gonna wake up
that stream we put out pepper we put out
mace to throw off the dogs out the dogs
and we had our team go up and down these
little because it's about ten foot tall
bank and we're in this little creek or
stream had water in it mm-hm and so I
was trying to lose the dogs we neuter
coming at night and now it's dark and we
contain up that stream for a while I
wanted to get as far away from them as
we could because Sal had climbed a tree
and said they're coming he pointed out
he told half there were hundreds of them
coming with lights they all had lanterns
and the dogs were getting closer so he
could clean up that stream for another
hour to at night doing still going out
putting down the mace to me finally went
up to the bank on the right set up our
own in for the night he rested overnight
and I'm facing the bank and the other
seven guys are around and so again we
hear the dogs the people so we there and
that our onf maybe two or three hours to
guys come up up the stream with a
lantern burning brightly and they go
pass this Lantern goes out and they come
back as a compact hep coughs and then
they stopped and I think that's where
you're going next well yeah that's here
here it is one of the envier and the
creek started crawling up the embankment
toward me I was still facing the creek
the NVA soldier was good he only moved
when the wind stirred the trees for a
moment my thoughts drift to summer camp
in New Hampshire years earlier when we
played capture the flag on those clear
summer nights my favorite trick was to
use the woods to get as close to the
flag as
possible now my mind was racing 100
miles per hour and I realized I was the
flag and he was closing in he was too
close for me to tell anyone on my team
the jungle that night seemed deadly
quiet except of course when the wind
stirred as the NVA soldier crawled
closer I remembered thinking that my
heart was beating so damn loud that Ho
Chi Minh could hear it in Hanoi I
flashed back to my childhood when we
used to play hide-and-go-seek on West
Paul Avenue in Trenton New Jersey one of
my favorite hiding places was behind the
hedges and missed him and misses a
meiko's front yard
I remember worrying that Teddy zabrowski
or John Wayne Austin or worse Barbara
Pointon would find me because they could
hear my heart beating so loud I tried to
comfort myself by thinking that because
I had not been running in recent hours
my heartbeat shouldn't be too loud yet
my heart sounded like a kettle drum
during Beethoven's ninth
no matter the NVA soldier kept moving up
the embankment I was very impressed with
his stealth I could barely hear him then
it happened during one windy moment I
heard movement very close to me it was
only a slight sound but a sound
nonetheless before the wind stopped the
NVA soldier touched the sole of my size
10 our army issue
jungle boot I heard it's like gasp of
surprise from him at that moment I had a
death grip on my car 15 I had it on
single-shot a car 15 on full automatic
sounds much different from the bark of
an ak-47 on full automatic if I had to
shoot it would be single shots for a
millisecond I wondered if my left foot
was far enough to the left so that when
I fired it I wouldn't shoot myself time
Stood Still my pucker factor was minus
zero after a few of the longest seconds
of my life the wind stirred but there
was no movement
he remained still after what seemed like
an eternity the wind stirred again and I
heard the NVA moved backward just
slightly he was so cool I knew he was
facing me I wondered why I couldn't hear
his heart the jungle around us remained
pitch-black
as my twilight zone moment yeah yeah
that's uh that's that's craziness and
you think he was you think he just
decided like this this guy's probably
got the drop on me and I want to live
what do you think he decided I believe
so cuz that there had been any other
movement at all then he would have been
on the receiving end of the five five
six mm-hmm so he didn't he made a
tactical decision to live yeah thank God
yeah because they know then obviously
once you started shooting the gay gigs
up and you would have been beep right on
your trail clothes and had it happen I
mean I thought was if I just did one
single shot could the muzzle flash will
light up where he was and then I was
hoping to it would take no more than a
second shot to finish him off so that
the jungle they would hear gunshots but
they weren't wouldn't be quite sure
where was this and people that haven't
spent time out in the woods or out in
the jungle it can get completely pitch
black in the jungle is that what this
was was just like complete like he's you
could barely even could you see his face
at all nothing I mean like knew he was
there you sit there you could feel your
hand in front of your nose when you
shake and move it back and forth you can
feel the breeze from your hand but you
can't see it yeah so for those of you
that haven't been in this it's when you
get at nighttime and then it's a cloudy
night and then you're in triple-canopy
jungle there's no light now I can't see
anything and that's what this situation
is absolutely well luckily you you you
got out of that and then you guys
continue on going back to the book by 9
o'clock we had located the LZ and
secured it the clear area at several
feet of grass on it and the ground was
at an angle because it was on the side
of the mountain again we heard dogs are
our tactical scenarios stunk we were in
a relatively open area on a hillside
with minimal cover and the NVA had the
high ground times seem to be our worst
enemy although having limited ayers air
resources didn't improve our mood
finally the other team was extracted
without taking further casualties and
spider was overhead taking ground fire
from the north of the LZ he
the trusty and reliable Marine Corps
uh-1b gunships with the radio call signs
Scarface were seconds away as we heard
the choppers approaching us one of the
top offers that Sal and son had planted
exploded exploded so you guys were doing
that too you guys set booby traps on
them on the enemy set claymores on them
right which would really piss him off oh
yeah try to ruin their parade yeah we
knew the NVA were going to be hopping
mad now that's some gentle way of
putting it spider was able to vector the
Scarface gunship to our location quickly
there was no time for orientations we
pop smoke and seconds later the first
Scarface chopper roared in the jungle
north of us erupted with small arms fire
the second Scarface chopper roared and
so closer I could see the facial
expressions on the door gunner as he
blasted the area north of our LZ with
his m60 machine gun both Scarface both
Scarface aircraft took several hits when
the sky Raiders made their passes they
also took hits from small-arms fire that
sounded like ak-47s during the second
gun run Sal blew a Claymore in the face
of an NVA scout Sal then blew a second
Claymore and returned to the LZ
reporting more NVA troops right behind
him and you guys this is another
interesting SOP and we would do this to
carry claymores I didn't do that
I only rephrase that we would we got
trained to do this you know you know
jungle situation right you guys would
make claymores with like five second and
ten second fuses on them right don't put
them down pull the fuse and you're on
yeah and run I never used one of those
I'm very thankful that I did not yeah
yeah apparently the combination of air
assets and our forty millimeter barrage
has slowed the NVA troops long enough
for the extraction ships to come to the
LZ spider told me that the hundred first
Airborne Division was going to extract
us the Marine Corps gunships would make
one more gun run and for the first time
st idaho Slick's from the 101st Airborne
Division would follow right behind them
and get as close to the LZ as possible
we were used to the king bees and knew
most of the pilots on a first-name basis
101st pilots were good too but because
this was our first
with 101st Airborne Division slicks I
told Sean King that they had to be the
first people to approach the ship and
that they had to alert the young door
Gunners that thought that five of our
men were Vietnamese that's a crazy thing
to think about oh absolutely
so you got the head we had horrible
results when they would only weren't
careful and again you know young door
Gunners first come in the country and if
they're not breathed properly because
our guys dressed they're ugly they're
not that they would look like nv8 but
there they weren't Americans
mm-hmm we've had team members that lost
Vietnamese that way yeah
tragically we when Roger Hayden was on
he told a story of the same thing he had
they had they had Vietnamese Scouts and
they were doing a hammer and anvil
operation with a platoon they hadn't
worked with before that was new in
country and there was some mix-up was on
the insertion and you know just some
mistakes that compound it and anyways
these guys the the anvil portion was
waiting and the first guys that came out
of the tree line were their vietnamese
Scouts yeah and they got they got lit up
you know we were in in when I was in
Ramadi we I you know you see like
pictures of seals with like beards and
all that oh yeah and look at all like
everyone shaved and everyone we wore
regular uniforms to what the army and
what the Marine Corps war why because
that exact reason you know you swing
around the corner and you've got a 19
year old on a 50 Cal and he sees some
guy with a beard and a gun there's a
chance you're getting shot where as an
American you know because because the
jihadist would have beards right and in
Ramadi we just didn't everything we
could do to identify ourselves as good
guys did now your jihadist could have
everything from m16s over carbines to a
case you didn't know what they'd be
carrying yeah and they also won't be new
archives at a case or ks's yeah the
other thing was they were they wore
paramilitary outfits price they wore
camis they wore body armor sometime they
wore helmets sometimes so yeah that's
amazing that you guys did and also you
had the you had the cognizance to say
hey wait a second we've never worked for
these helicopters before
get out there and tell them we got some
Vietnamese folks coming their way with
ak-47s yeah they were pissed because you
and King went down to the first chopper
nobody else followed I said you make
sure you tell them then you give me the
green light then we'll send some little
people and then bub and I got on the
second extract and there's two of the
things on that mission their King had
experimental pump m79 which he carried
he'd held five rounds and we we thought
we'd try it once mm-hmm but he carried
it for five day well that four whole
five days we were on the ground and so
at that LZ it worked and imagine five
m79 rounds go off 240 millimeters then
also one night was a night that the
Russians flew over us and did a resupply
and we were begging for moon beam this
show up because somebody on a Russian
ass but the whole side of mountain lit
up is a weirdest damn thing we ever saw
so that was like a signalling device for
that was signaling devices that the that
the Vietnamese were using to have the
Russians drop the resupply and they were
doing resupplies to the Vietnamese what
language did you speak my foreign
language is English so they pushed us
through and they waved the wave the
language required because by 68 they
knew we had a SF had a strong
interpreter core got it like my cap he
spoke four languages he'd been educated
in France and he corrected my English
and he was a smartass on top a little
fucker but he was our little guy yeah
yeah yeah awesome going back to the book
the extraction was slick and quick when
as we pulled out the automatic L as we
pulled out the LZ the slick took several
hits three of us returned full automatic
fire from our car 15s I threw a white
phosphorus grenade as the area north of
the LZ lit up with dozens of muzzle
flashes from ak-47s and SKS's the green
tracers from the ak-47s appeared as
though they were coming between my legs
I was told later that as our slick
pulled out of the LZ the air Scarface
gunships laid down a full fuselage fused
a lot of of suppressing fire the lead
marine aircraft piloted by Lieutenant
Colonel Robinson had the
plexiglass windshield blown out of the
aircraft in addition his chopper in the
second gunship had taken more than a
dozen hits and yeah that's that's that's
that's the yes pilot you were saying yes
he was riding you and riding you and the
way you tell the book
colonel does this mean the next time
we're in trouble you and we call for
Scarface you won't respond to the Bell
hell no Robinson responded I never said
that
it just pisses me off with my aircraft
gets shot up parts are hard to come by
and I'd rather be flying fearless and
you know he continued on here I went
back to my room so this is after that
crazy operation you got early make it
out for the hundredth time that you you
you dance in deaths face I went back to
my room and picked up a news magazine
with a picture on the front page about
the biggest latest anti-war protests a
side insane whose side were they on they
hadn't seen charlie like st idaho head
they never they never asked sow hip and
other Vietnamese men on my team what
they felt about the war what a day s3
refused to pull us out when we were
ready for extraction
then s3 questioned my integrity despite
the fact that we were only minutes away
from fighting NVA in close quarters
battle had not scarface the ae1 ES and
the 101st airborne slicks defended us
from the sky and there are people back
in the states protesting this war I
shook my head dropped my rucksack and
Webb gear picked up a small ammo belt
holding several magazines of 556 ammo
and went to the s3 to get a jeep the
dentist was only a short drive up the
road but I kept my trusty car 15 nearby
anyway I went to the dentist got my
tooth pulled and drew new rations and
PRC 25 batteries and the reason I read
all that is to read this line right here
the next day the next day st idaho got
shot out of five L Z's yeah once in the
morning and once in the afternoon
and by that time when we got inserted on
that mission error we had gone a couple
days the same thing in the morning gets
shot out and one of those missions on
the primary LZ when the king bee was
going in mm-hmm
Sal saw a wire across the El Xena
how does Sally even see a wire and a
helicopter were going in he saw it he
told the door gunner fortunately the
Vietnamese thing was quick and they were
able to swerve away and a1 came in and
hit that but was a 500-pound bomb they
knew we were coming and we've been
compromised we never realized how
seriously we've been compromised and
that was proof hardened roof and we are
guys so tar I switched a lot of
Vietnamese around you so your guys were
some of your Vietnamese we're getting
burned out well sure because you know
you you do that long flight go out to
the LZ then you go in and get shot out
shot out shot out fly back get lunch get
a new target sometimes they just say
here's your next target
cubby wouldn't know where would be we
wouldn't even have any kind of
background or anything let's just they
wanted to get a team on the ground go
back and then we did it again Bam Bam
Bam and sometimes were you in so you're
feeding me sometimes say I've had enough
of this who's your main who's your main
alazai south my counterpart he was the
assistant team leader he was the
Vietnamese team leader and who is the
other American that would be with you at
that point in time was Bubba John's sure
he came on the team in November when I
became to10 at the end of October and
these guys were all freaked out too cuz
you were like young oh yeah and what
were you uh what was your rank at that
time well by then I've been promoted to
an e4 because I remember I got promoted
yeah I'm an e deuce in camp with the
built for ei Torre nine on the recon
team so Spyder probably got referred it
back to PFC said now roll up your
sleeves so people think you're a
sergeant we don't want them no you're
just a dummy spfc
instead of by October we were able to
expect for and then when Jim wanted off
the team which we respected and Tuesday
I respected never I'll never say a word
against him on it then Bubba came on so
November that's my boo boo he was the
one one and then our not one missing
King came along I just felt funny about
I wanted a little extra firepower and he
wanted to try that that pump and 79 yeah
why not just going off on a mission to
test out that day yeah we had that uh
they sent us some thermobaric grenades
for the m79 and really yeah and and then
they called a week later and said hey
did you guys get a chance
was actually Lafe I think Lafe dumped of
like an entire load out of them on one
operation and anyways they call back
they say hey did you guys we're
wondering if you got a chance to use
those ther Emmonak thermobaric crew
dates yet like where we use them all
send more is the feedback do not wait oh
yeah and also is that speaking of that
as one of our side missions we always
carried eldest son or Italian green
which would be enemy ordnance doctor to
explode in her face so when we would go
along a trail like with that big trail
we crossed it we go down and dump a
little of the ammo so if anybody was see
the ammo they pick it up and then if we
ever came across a cache a which only
happened a few times we would put the
bad ammo in their cache a so they'd use
it for psyops never blow up on their
face yeah I was a good psyops thing when
they oh there was there was another
mission where you talk about where they
killed the Americans but they let the
boy and the Vietnamese go that was there
January 1st 69
all right speaking of holiday season
here's Christmas Day 1968 you're
inserted into like some really tall
elephant grass
there's NVA around you going back to the
book do to the elephant grass both in
terms of the noise we were making howl
muffle how it muffled on other sounds we
couldn't tell exactly how many NVA were
moving or if they were even NVA Black
said I smell smoke either our hand
grenades or the NVA have started fires
things are really heating up on the LZ
literally i radioed spider I told him we
were surrounded and had fires on two
sides of our perimeter I told him that
if the king bees didn't get in here ASAP
st idaho would be engaged in fighting
fires as well as firefights we're really
making these punny jokes of in the
middle of these situations sometimes you
have to laugh to keep from crying
they're starting more fires Bubba said
by now the noise from the fire forces to
raise our voices when we were talking to
each other the smoke was getting thicker
I began to sweat we threw a few more
hand grenades down the hill to force the
NVA to keep their heads down the
southern fire so just so everyone
understands this is what's actually
happening you're in elephant grass dry
elephant grass and it's burning on
multiple sides of your position which is
12 to 15 feet tall the elephant grass so
your visibility is like five feet three
feet yeah minimal and it's filled with
smoke you know and getting worse or we
wish you merry Chris yeah the southern
fires intensity grew by the second and
continued to move up the slope towards
us and around to the east there was fire
or fires to the north and northeast but
they weren't heading toward SD Idaho
with the speed of the southern flames by
now the smoke was so thick I had my
green cravat over my face and pulled up
over my nose burning embers from the
South kicked up and flew over our small
jagged perimeter dumping ashes soot and
small burning sparks on the elephant
grass and
only hip Antoine wore hats several LS
soaked our hair black told me that the
NVA weren't far behind the flames to
wanted reported seeing images a short
distance behind the flames to the south
and southeast
captain Tuan knew exactly where we were
as he brought the age 34 down the canyon
toward us seconds became ours my vision
was clearer than ever and I was a call
acutely aware of the smoke fire popping
sounds and enemy gunfire I stood on the
western edge of the perimeter waving a
colored panel skyward trying to catch
the pilots eye the h-34 continued its
slow-motion descent all I saw was the
bottom of the chopper with the front of
the struts sticking out to the right and
left coming down like a giant praying
mantis the rotor wash from the king bee
began to hit us finally the choppers
nose turned slightly to the left and I
could see captain twonk seeing his face
seeing him sitting in there so calmly in
the pilot's seat made my confidence
surge we would survive and then you guys
you guys you know can't get around get
it under control
well under control as you can and you
start boarding the chopper chopper has
the last man boarded the chopper I
signal to the door gunner to exit the
area as I sat in the door i sat in the
door as Tuan lifted the king be straight
up for several feet before heading south
as we pulled away from the null fire
swept up the hill and engulf the area
where we had been standing moments
earlier oh yeah maybe Christmas at
Paul's
captain Tuan roared down the canyon we
had chugged only a short while ago i
radioed spider and gave him a team okay
once again st idaho entered that magical
post mission moment the adrenaline was
still flowing
we had survived another target every
breath of air was sweeter
there was no fault of Christmas mom or
holiday presence our gift was to be
alive
that Christmas 1968 would haunt me
sporadically for more than 25 years
after a while I was able to stop sitting
upright sweating with fear when the
nightmares hit it's been almost 10 years
since I had that dream but every
Christmas nightmares are not I always
take a moment to think of Captain Tuan's
courage no sweat
King bees never rest yeah so that was uh
this is that's that's just a crazy
situation oh yeah close and then this is
like on Thanksgiving was when we had a
mission down south where our six-man
recon team the colonel tells you to find
three missing NVA divisions the first
the third and seventh we found him how'd
that work out for you it was pretty
intense to use the we use more than one
of those five second fuses to hold it
back yeah yeah that is data again that's
that's why you need to buy this book and
read this book if you want to hear about
the eight-man spike team versus a
division when that day was three three
divisions for those either don't scan I
mean that's that's thirty thirty
thousand men roughly and yeah that's
where those those five second fuse those
five second fuses just so everybody
understands what that means you're
trying to escape the enemy of a little
thing called the claymore mine it's like
the size of a book maybe a little bit
bigger and it's got a bunch of ball
bearings on one side the 555
50 ball bearings on one side that are
that spray out when when this thing
explodes and those are so like wound
people how many of those things did you
guys carry every everybody had one on
the team and then a 1:1 or always carry
two or three so you guys had lawless c4
yeah leaves and so what these guys would
do so you can use them for a bunch of
different reasons and one of the one of
the things that you guys did a lot with
them and this is again these are things
that I was trained in when I was first
got the SEAL Teams they - okay when you
set up a when you're gonna sleep at
night or you're gonna set up a rest
overnight position you're gonna put out
claymores and that way if you get
attacked in the middle night boom you
can light off the claymores and you can
get some fire superiority or at least
shock the enemy or do some damage to him
so you guys did that all the time but
then you made these little five-second
fuses knowing that if you're running
away you can just put this thing up a
you know put in the ground real quick or
put it up against the tree oh yeah you
always want to have it up against the
tree or something to take the backpack
on easily when you put it in and you got
the last four seconds before it explodes
you're running you can still you want to
make sure that you got a little protect
on the blacklist
we used to detonate those things at a
completely own safe distance behind them
oh I like I look back now and I'm
thinking why were we doing
WTF times - yeah yeah it's like let baby
we play the game let's find out or you
relate the limb blocks yeah yeah so you
started to tell that story a little bit
for those that you didn't catch the
whole story the story was Lin Black was
trying to figure out what it would take
to knock somebody out with c4 so C 4 s 6
feet yeah c4 just explodes there's no
shrapnel in it you can put shrapnel in
it but you don't have to so it's just
it's just a big concussion soul in black
was trying to figure out how much c4 it
would take so we can stun a guy so we
can grab them so we can get a Pio W so
that we can get a five day Liberty
anywhere in the world anywhere and $100
cash and so he so the way he the way he
experimented with this was by doing it
to himself
yeah just standing around at the range
and blasting
with heavier heavier weight until he got
knocked out everybody thought I
succeeded he his hearing was bad for a
few days yeah this hair was Oh see now
in the trial sweetie I don't know if
this in the SEAL Teams that would have
been weird he used a new guy for that we
would use the new guy like okay let's
see if this works I'll do let's win this
win the stun guns the tasers first came
in right it wasn't fun to be a new guy
because we had to see how those things
work right so we uh we used to
experiment that so yeah that's that
story's just crazy and you and you
looking down and seeing the firing Golf
the place that you just got picked out
oh yeah
instantly sure is this like one of those
moments in time was the same thing like
on Thanksgiving Day we gotta strike that
they were coming out of the jungle
running at port arms and so they would
be try to come down so me and the door
gunner but just literally stopped him
and they're trying like one of those
cartoons you see on the TV were the guys
running and stops and gets jank they
would just push them right back in the
jungle before they even fell down and
that was just yeah you just you don't
forget those things they stick we the
next chapter is called a Happy New Year
oh the day after Christmas the s3 brass
asked SD Idaho to run another ma target
and Laos I respectfully declined citing
fatigue and general weirdness I didn't
tell the brass that I had a funny
feeling about the target I felt
apprehensive for some reason back at fo
b1 around 1200 hours someone from the
commotion came into the club and said a
Vietnamese team member from RT ass was
on the radio talking to spider that was
very bad news
several the recon team members in fo b1
headed toward the combo shot before we
got there Tony her L a veteran recon man
came around the corner with some more
bad news they were hit by sappers it
doesn't look good it appeared the
Americans and been slow to react in a
matter of seconds the sappers killed the
three SF troops and chose to leave the
South Vietnamese team members alive
the news about the sappers was a triple
dose of bad news first
we had three dead Green Berets second
reports one zeroes had received four
months about NVA sappers being a leaf
lethal force were now confirmed third by
killing only the Americans the NVA
pulled off a major psychological coup by
leaving the NV that by leaving the
Vietnamese team members alive their
survival would plant seeds of doubt and
dissension between SF troops and our
little people and then you guys were
heading north the 101st Airborne
Division choppers carried the six men
south when the choppers landed on the
helicopter pad Colonel Jack Warren had
ordered every man in fo b4 out to the
site
he was held in high regard by SF troops
because he genuinely cared about his men
it had been said that because of his
dedication to the SF mission and the men
of SF he would never advance beyond the
rank of colonel
he'd remained an SF too long a career
decision that the traditional army
hierarchy despised and punished ASP was
from fob 4fo before which Warren
commanded after the three corpses were
unloaded from the helicopter Warren gave
a terse teary-eyed speech to his captive
audience
Warren warned everyone that if they were
careless in the field death was the
result of that carelessness then he bent
down open to body bag and picked up a
portion of a body of one of the Dead
Americans
he was now crying and screaming at his
men to never be careless in the field
Warren was never the same after that
neither was C&C
what what was it that changed from your
perspective
well we from our early briefings
probably in October we heard about the
NVA sapper teams they were highly
trained and they would just wear a
loincloth
carry a weapon and they're really just
highly trained in tracking so that when
they came to the attack part they have
minimal clothing and they knew what they
were looking for and the NVA at that
point had a metal kill American metal so
if they killed us they got their medal a
bonus and there would be heroes for the
rest of their lives within the communist
party so we heard about him this
confirmed it and it just kicked up
everybody's concerned a notch and that
being New Year's Eve the team had the
America's had taken a bottle of scotch
with him so they had had a little hint
of the Scotch we don't know how much and
that's what Jack Warren had going the
extra distance on saying about being
careless we don't know mm-hmm but that
sappers were good and that proved it and
it just gave us in our case you know as
you know for you do your RN at night
without the dogs he would do your
perimeter and our people always checked
him and we always rotate who's be
sleeping who wouldn't and we never ever
had a problem with that no matter how
tired you are to be somebody awake just
so something like that happened somebody
be there on four or Matic ready they
respond new level terror yeah and those
guys were so it's like just traveling
super light and super select the sappers
sure you know just could move quickly
and yeah it's a scary yeah okay because
you know the we knew that the NVA had
other sources set up besides being
compromised in headquarters they also
had people that alerted when the
choppers left the launch site mm-hmm
they have border watchers so that when
we came in they would report where we
were heading
to a higher command and they would try
to rally their troops so we were up
against that at all times just a
question of who would be there how many
and a lot of times just getting on the
ground was the first part but then you
hope to get into the mission and it was
just really a challenge speaking of a
challenge here we're going back to the
book the daily grind of running missions
across the fence was wearing on me
physically and mentally as 69 dawned I
began a mental examination of life in
SOG being in an elite unit within
America's finest Special Operations was
where I wanted to be the adrenaline
enhanced high of deadly fire fights
against a relentless enemy under
extremely lopsided odds was intoxicating
I had never experienced such
exhilaration or sheer terror if there
was a little voice in the back of my
head which spoke of survival surviving
not only a vigorous enemy campaign
directed against to SOG members but
merely surviving the odds of going home
in one piece my mind also began the
mental debate between rising to the new
challenges inherent in a secret war and
returning to a safer assignment my
one-year tour of duty was scheduled to
end at the end of April under the
general rules of SOG after running
targets across the fence for six months
I could request a cushy assignment I had
already spent seven months with the team
I was alive however thanks to hip Sal
fuck Tuan and the other men of SDI doh
I couldn't just walk away
and that's where you that's where you
wrap up this book now you go into some
cool you go into some cool well one more
really interesting story and then you
you also have a very cool thing in there
about what you guys carried and what we
didn't carry and what you didn't carry
how much so how much longer so now it's
January of 69 yeah you've been there for
seven months how much longer did you
stay with the C and C teams I'll stay
right there to the end we we closed F
will be one in January they shipped us
down to Danang and that's where I picked
up with the second book and they needed
help down ere so we hit the ground
continue to run Bubba asked the tape be
taken off the team
so he left limb black came on so with
linen on for my last couple of months
and at the very end they had a mission
up at the media pass which was north of
the DMZ River in layoffs which was a
major channel point and the plan was for
us to go in set up on a mountaintop
taking a lot of claymores mortars and
calling airstrikes for two or three days
on that just to raise hell with the NVA
there because they never had a recon
team go that far north and we did an
inspection which is that inspection
prior to that mission which was about
April 20th 69 and then we finally went
up to the launch site and we're up there
I guess maybe it's about the 24th or
25th I just forget the exact date now
but we went up to the launch site got on
the chopper is we getting ready to
launch the choppers take off and they
turn around went back and he and that
target had just had two aircraft shot
down over it they figured they just shot
down a phantom jet and a sky reader
choppers are gonna be easy to knock out
this guy
so to sidebar to that I met her being
two years ago one of the guys that ran
recon says remember those pictures you
got on the second book on the ground
yeah yeah he says what was that mission
wasn't that something like that's a
suicide mr. right and says well I don't
know about suicide it was gonna be high
odds but you know we were gone and we
had two extra Americans we were we had
em sixties we got beaucoup bullets hand
grenades we were gonna give the shot the
guy goes do you realize they asked me to
do that and I told her fuck off I go
really
I says you saw us taking these pictures
you didn't tell me that says I didn't
know what your mission was so here's a
top-secret operation
the recon guys another recon man had
been given that target said he'll now it
was too far north and he just felt that
the it would just be a suicide missed
and once you get in you never get out
other than a casket or a body bag but
there's no talking between teens much
because everything is like you got a
mission you do your mission they do
theirs so yeah well I already gave you a
fair warning before we started this that
we're probably to have to have you come
back on here okay I got just I mean this
this these books are there's awesome the
the detail that you go on to and just
the experience that you've had which are
just it's a miracle that you're sitting
here talking and able to tell us what
you went through when as far as I can
tell there's no way in hell you should
be sitting here right now I agree I mean
there are times when and talking to
friends of our people have read the book
you know particular on page 202 what the
god touches your booth I mean I've
talked to people it's just like it feels
surreal even today it's like thank God
everybody at home was praying you know
and you know the last thing I want to
read from the book is just just this
section right here
the dedication it says this book is
dedicated to all SOG reconnaissance team
members both US Special Forces and
indigenous troops as well as to every
man in every air support unit especially
the king bee pilots of the 219th South
Vietnamese Air Forces Special Operations
Squadron
who worked daily with sog teams on the
ground across the fence in America's
secret war this book is also for every
man in SOG and their support units who
made the ultimate sacrifice
yeah because today as we sit here
there's still 1589
Americans missing in action in Southeast
Asia from the Vietnam War that includes
CIA SF Regular Army and layoffs alone 50
Green Berets are amongst those mas over
140 Aviation Army Marine Corps Air Force
mi ace died supporting our missions here
does help deadly it was you guys had a
over 100% casualty rate
yeah some of our guys had multiple
Purple Hearts Bob Howard received eight
he had been put in for 11 he he was a
recipient of the Medal of Honor in
December of 68 for a mission out of
Kanto and yeah the casualty rate did
exceed 100% the and I I didn't I
couldn't find any numbers on the numbers
that were actually killed but that was a
massive number percentage-wise of guys
in SOG that were killed right yeah the
numbers are hard to track and I'm
working with a gal now who's a real
she's a retired Master Sergeant from
101st she's began to do some research to
try to put that in ever together because
during a war 3.2 million Americans
served in Vietnam that includes the
500,000 sailors they were off off the
coast and your seals that were going up
north and out of that 20,000
approximately 20,000 were SF
out of the SF approximately 2,000 went
to SOG out of that depends on which
author you talk to there's no hard stats
any worse because SF was not as good as
the seals and keeping records and it be
between five hundred and seven maybe
eight hundred Green Berets
he went across the fence with recon
missions out of the 3.2 million those
are our numbers yeah amazing well I hope
you don't mind coming back here and be
honored to come back because I've heard
some of your stories pal believe my
stories are a big joke I conversed with
one of one of the guys that was in
Ramadi with me a guy by the name of Dave
Burke he was he was a Marine Corps
angler cool guy on the ground with us
and you know we always joke about our
about why our experiences you know he
had a friend and we had him on the
podcast who served in World War 2 Korea
and Vietnam really he was a Purple Heart
recipient in every war in every one of
those Wars and you know that's the way I
feel standing here talking to you like
I'm in a totally different and much
lower category of experience but that's
why it's such an honor to sit here and
talk with well that's mutual if you have
any other closing thoughts - well the
only thing about this book actually
respond to mentioned that ya couldn't
have done it without my wife awesome my
dear wife Anna at the time we had four
teenagers and one newborn in the house
and so you can imagine that turmoil and
I'm working at a fish rapper up in North
County and so between the fish rapper
and the kids she goes go write the book
awesome she's supporting all that is one
thing real quick yeah you got home from
so you got out and shortly thereafter
when you got a done with Vietnam is that
that's when you were done right you got
out of the Army shortly thereafter yeah
I went back to to C&C
for a second tour and then I got the
army in the April 25 s what book 2 is
about going back one tour wasn't enough
at cnz well you know what they all
honest with you I came back in betar
land in the state's like May 1 May 2nd
of 69 the anti-war movement going on
strong there was Woodstock our men
walked on the moon but I hated I hated
being and we were and I supposed to go
to Fort Bragg with the regular SF but
they person 10th Special Forces Group
was is up in Massachusetts and they had
five company
ABCD and E he was a signal company which
was rinky-dink they had new lieutenants
butter bars running this thing and they
treated like Basie kampot us up then to
top it off they had old career sergeants
are all overweight all an embarrassment
to the beret they wore and they came in
and put me up with two sergeant I'm in
this environment that was not a good
chemistry mm-hmm
so I heard that the MPS were coming
basically and I went down to Pentagon we
had a woman Billie Alexander who handled
our orders and I was told what kind of
wine and what flowers she liked so
before I went down there I had her wine
her flowers and then Thursday morning I
get to the Pentagon at seven o'clock
give her the flowers no wine went back
to sleep in the parking lot came back at
4:00 she gave me the orders to Nam I
cleared on Friday the MPS came on Monday
and I was back at my team little later
for the MPS covered for some bar fights
property destruction they have your
portion of a 4-4-2 which I had a time
for four to w-30 which is what Austin
Oldsmobile
oh god I've got that for four to kill
y'all sorry yeah yeah it's a 69 which
was the coolest car at the time hear me
to her sure the reports about that car
going through the entrance gate on a
sideways drift
I saw sorry when it entered the base
only exit gate that's what it was the
MPS weren't happy about that they
couldn't catch me and I was able to hide
within our comic Whitman but they were
trying to begin to figure things out but
anyways they were coming sounds like it
sounds like the next podcast warm up for
the next podcast we'll we'll take it
from there next time like a bad dream
I'll be back if you ask thank you no
that's awesome these books across the
fence which one you think people should
ride read first across the fence is the
first that's gonna book about my getting
involved in etc and these stories of
other people which by the way we have a
green beret medic John Walton who was
the son of Sam Walton your hair of a
store called Walmart and son one of the
best medics there was at the time
chapter 4 where fellow green break is
his leg blown off
and the fun of the Vietnamese got south
four times John brought them all back
and Tom Cunningham's alive today and has
two children thanks to John that's
awesome
these books are available in Amazon
Amazon go to Amazon durability books or
paperbacks the website is SOG Chronicles
calm SOG chronicles calm that's the name
of Volume one that's another book right
and then on the ground the secret war in
Vietnam as the second book the second
book if then here there are some stories
I missed because of deadlines right and
the first story we have the our recon
team is in our worst target Oscar eight
and the NVA come up and tap them on the
shoulder and say it's your turn for
guard duty oh that's pretty close to the
enemy alright we will cover these books
in the future everyone go buy these
books or you're ready and get a really
true honor to have you on appreciate it
honor be here and I can't wait to have
you back
he turned outstanding thank you and with
that mr. John Stryker Meyer has left the
building and what an honor was to talk
to him and I can absolutely promise
we're having that guy back on and thanks
to you John for your for your service
and your sacrifice and the sacrifices of
your teammates it is men like you that
have allowed us to live the way that we
live and that is in freedom so he has
left the building and echo speaking of
living mm-hmm living the way we should
live what do you got for us well as we
have been doing talking about jujitsu
first mmm-hmm jujitsu martial arts you
know capability is what it is that's
really what it is generalize like the
whole thing into one big nugget
capability just improve it we want to
improve our capabilities
oh yeah sure a way to do that not just
in the Marshall Fields
but in life you know is to train some of
that jiu-jitsu yeah I was talking
there's a girl named Cara who trains
here you know I see her every once in a
while Elsie or whatever move and she she
said basically the stuff we were saying
where she was I was like but I only see
her sort of in the men's class and I
said hey have you tried the women's
classes our women's cause it's good now
developed and then she was like not yet
I want to whatever and I was like yeah
that's I think a lot of the times will
offer more benefits depending on who you
are as a girl will offer benefits
because you can get like the moves you
can kind of do you know on on a body
that's more similar to yours so you can
go through the moves a little bit like
more thoroughly I think in a way for
lack of a better way of putting and she
was like yeah that's good that's true
she's like you know what though I I
really like there's a lot of value here
in the guys in the men's class and she
said straight for self-defense for sure
and I was like yeah she's like yeah
because like when you get used to guys
and meanwhile there's like two guys
rolling like hard though you're the kind
where they're rolling and they're
grunting it right in front of us like
sweating his split this list was slash
you know she's like when you get with
butt and we kind of laugh because we she
like motions to them and I'm thinking
like yeah any girl to come in and see
that or anyone even anyone even
participate in that yeah I think you not
gotta do that no way men ready for that
a lot of girls are not ready for that
oh yeah and what if you would just all
of a sudden like one day you go to the
grocery store and loans now you got to
deal with that man that's that's tough
because it's a big psychological gap you
need to make up oh yeah
train jujitsu the ganas made up she was
like I'm used to and she's not a big
girl either she's just like a pretty
small girl she's like yeah and she's
real nice you know nice ago she's like
yeah and I'm really used to that and
I've been training for like almost a
year now
I'm like a big difference that's that's
good that you can come in here as often
as you do and have that mindset that's
good that's gonna get you places 100% so
we're talking about jiu-jitsu oh yeah
and then you need to start talking about
the gear that is needed for ninjutsu yes
some of the gear that you need for did
you do is Iggy yes if you're gonna train
key jiu-jitsu which we recomm
strong strongly recommend we also
recommend you train Oggy you trained all
kinds of jujitsu yeah that's what you
trained if you need Aggie which you do
get one from orange mane
yep or Jin so he go to origin main
dot-com is raking at all these things
also jeans American denim again we all
know this but I'm gonna say it again
it's all made in America all of it yeah
every little piece of it the little
seeds that they plant to eventually grow
cotton to eventually go into the loom to
eventually formulate weave yes formulate
both the fabric that gets sewn and
stitched into Gea's jeans rash guards
all this stuff shorts their shorts in
the world too by the way
actually um anyway all of it is in
American done in America so boom there's
that huge deal by the way so yeah
American denim has we have some new
jeans good ones jogger you know sweat
pants wet athletic gear boom origin main
their supplements mmm big deal pretty
much all the essential supplements that
you're gonna need as you go through this
kind hectic path at times the path is
hectic it should be yeah it's easy
that's not the path we want to be on
yeah this as that path leads down yeah
it's gonna be easy if it's a downhill
situation because all you gotta do is
sit there and slide don't take the path
down yeah so yes the supplements are
joint warfare for your joints joint
warfare is more for like if you have get
abuse on your joint you're running a lot
you you're doing jiu-jitsu where you're
twisting a lot and you're going everyday
or something like this or you're just
lifting everyday lifting everyday oh
yeah basically if you're doing physical
activity yeah that's kind of like hard I
mean I guess you could break it down
like oh if you're doing some weak
physical activity then you might not
need it but I think not that so much
that don't work for you made a good
point though at the muster because your
knee is like kind of on that I know on
the final stages of healing yeah and you
were like I was like how's your knee or
whatever and you're like would you say
oh it was good but like since I've been
standing up on it for a long time
I like her yeah at the muster yes it
actually swelled up again yes
surprisingly so here's the thing it made
me think when I was a bouncer used to
stand up all the time like for the whole
thing you're standing at the front door
and not the key and the and but I have
dress shoes on I don't have the the New
Balance or the you know the deal it's
like dress shoes so it's like it was her
man joint warfare what it came in well
you know varying levels of heart so get
some join warfare joints get some krill
oil for your joints that's general
maintenance and general maintenance of
live yes life support yes finding
discipline and discipline go which is
sort of like gives you a little bit of
that yeah little edge mentally shouldn't
be illegal negative if you are going to
confront someone in an intellectual
battle well is it legal for you to take
discipline go and they don't should not
be illegal because it's not any legal
drug it's not even drugs it's actually
the advantage though right yeah good we
lifting weights as an advantage live or
the results from lifting weights is an
advantage the results from eating salads
that's an advantage so boom same thing
but discipline just tastes really good
and and have that advantage over your
enemy whoever they may be yes then we
got out we also got milk which is
delicious delicious protein I had a
milkshake last night and meatloaf no
potatoes meatloaf carrots milkshake
that's a good meal right there
chocolate dark no the darkness and I put
peanut butter in it there is literally
my late dinner last night oh yeah that's
the milk and you can give it to your
kids too you can get that warrior kid
milk yeah for your kids
yeah so your kids so your kids instead
of turning out to be like an obese outta
shape kid
that you are like trying to know don't
even put them on that path put it on the
milk track let me ask you this when
you're young
yes and you went to whatever elementary
school or junior high or whatever did
you bring home lunch sometimes yeah
so not very often okay so do you it as
far as you can remember do you did you
have a healthy home lunch do you do with
your you know nothing we didn't even
know what healthy well like it wasn't
that wasn't even a thing yes so that's
yeah that was just like oh what do you
like to eat peanut and what do you like
to eat and what's cheap yes right cuz
we're gonna get you we're not getting
you cold cuts right cuz those cost money
guess what doesn't cost a lot of money
Polonia Jam PB and jam right jelly jo -
all day long yeah there's no honor on
white bread or white bread that's okay
on white bread and then you know what
you get the little bit a little party
mix of of potato chips Frito Lays
Doritos which I never liked Oreos I
still don't like to read those it's just
yeah but then you get some of that and
then like some chocolate chip some Chips
Ahoy cookies you know what those are
yes I did yeah get the sleep little
little mini sleeve a Chips Ahoy
yeah that's and so there's nothing
nutritional right the nutritional value
of this launch is zero yeah you had
nothing yeah that last case scenario I
used to get the chocolate milk it from
the you know what it cost five cents for
a chocolate for a white milk seven cents
for a chocolate milk or the high school
school lunch yo so I used to get that
that would probably be what I actually
lived off of because everything else was
just was just poisoned in a wrapper
basically yeah that's your question uh
well I mean the reason I was asking is
because okay so my family or my mom more
than my dad I guess but you know my mom
took care of the home lunches in the
event of us bringing a home lunch she
she's health conscious she was like a
hippie you know so we had like the whole
wheat bread okay you know the the and
then know what though you're how old are
you I will be 42 this year yeah so
you're like five years younger than me
there's no there's a difference
in terms of what people were even
thinking yeah yeah well keep in mind and
everyone wasn't like that I'm saying my
mom was my mom was like a hippie she was
different than everyone and here's
here's my point with that we're when
we'd come to school and I bring home
lunch we get to sorta teased because
it's like you don't get the cool snacks
the cool frito what I like relays and
chips and cookies in like the cool stuff
oh no than that open the milk negative
no you got we got the whole wheat
sandwich with like turkey from a real
turkey with sprouted grains on there
some elaborate hundred sorry about the
sprouted grain oh yes it is it is
nonetheless we got laughed at that any
mom Decco was coming in hard with the
spring read with a health yeah I never
was making fun of you cuz yeah it's like
cardboard I don't even know because they
don't know how to taste it it's not that
it's more of a social thing everyone
everyone knows that cookies are yummy
everyone knows that like chips are
delicious for snack and all this stuff
we didn't have that we had like the
snacks that they knew that weren't that
good tasting carrots and like carrots
are pretty tasty though I think so now
yeah I'm scared about cares if you're
not eating sugar and you eat a carrot
tastes sweet yeah it is you're like oh
this is super smells good you can eat
too many carrots because your body can't
digest them fully if you eat too many of
them just FYI
okay I've made that mistake before
pounding bags like one of those bags
carrots your gut is gonna tell you all
right you know the issue good noted but
where are you going wrong I'm making a
good point unless you even talk about
carrots a little bit more I can't we
can't but unless I make the point so
these kids would make fun of us because
they got the cookies and we had like
tomatoes and sprouts mmm you know
sandwiches yeah but growing up when you
come early adulthood
adulthood that health consciousness paid
off big-time huge time sure so to make
the switch from non health consciousness
to health consciousness it's like it's
it can be a grind that can be harder
yeah but half maintain the path and it's
already instilled as being a young
person so there's that so Mulk
so my daughter comes home from school
literally yesterday say they were
teasing me because I had Karen
mmm-hmm and she was she wasn't very
happy about it I was Russian knows
jujitsu start choking falls out well I
started to say that but youth it was no
time for jokes at this point cuz I'm
like are you serious or not oh you know
one choke anyone Frattini for your
carrots but this is what I said one of
the things I said I said don't worry
about them Tita there's a first off than
nothing funny about carrots like this
it's not I'm not saying it's like we're
so serious I'm just saying what's funny
about I don't get it kind of thing it's
just like yeah that's kind of true and I
was like and guess what carrots are good
for you just like your lunch is good for
you and as you grow up you're gonna see
the result of that and you're gonna see
the results of them not eating not
healthy food yeah and you're gonna see
you need to do better than that as a
father why because you know better yeah
no she needs to be like they say oh what
do you eatin peeve eating some you
eating some carrots yeah and then she
says what are you eating there some type
2 diabetes you're gonna die at age 32
loser
get out of my face before I put you to
sleep all right all the implement you
know that direction that's not part of
the way over where your kid code right
there no that's our having fun if on is
part of you know life but I saw her
wheels turning when she was like like
yeah
you know like I will see the results you
know and then you know then my wife's
there and she's like yeah look you're
good how big his muscles are all this
stuff right so kind of closer your boy
was kind of like just making stuff up
unless it work but go back to milk or
your kid milk this is what you achieved
with that one of the many things is you
actually made it like kind of cool to
have a healthy thing have a healthy
snack
we're gonna sway a lot of people with
these books and this this stuff I mean
I've seen it's not never gonna have it
is happening it's awesome see all right
dude we got a rockin off c'mon
well that was an important story a long
that was development anyway is deeper
online we got chocolate white tea how
about that doctor wait to tell me about
it
drink it tastes good deadlift 8,000
pounds certified organic but yep
certified organic and all that good
stuff
and it tastes delicious and it looks
cool so you're good and we have a store
it's called Chacko store so you go to
chocolate store calm this is where you
can get and get rash cards you can get
t-shirts uh-huh
you can get truckers hats and if you're
if you're not into truckers hats cuz
whatever you can get flex fit hats
flicks me too if ads are good you don't
get the judge hats you don't wear him
well they look stand down nod and down I
stand down anyway you want to represent
the path this is what it's for it's
quality stuff it's not ballpark giveaway
uh shirts the one you never wear you use
for like you know wiping your hands in
the kitchen or whatever it's not that
you're not gonna let bends in the
kitchen we're about quality quality yes
quality and representation um so yeah
some women's stuff on there yeah a lot
of good stuff I'm gonna happen two more
new shirts nice new I don't want to
necessarily say just shirts but two more
new items things sure coming out what's
down by for that also subscribed right
yes subscribe to what the podcast fur
we're not talking about subscribe to a
magazine cuz no one gets magazines
anymore magazines are dead sure right
buy a magazine now well you just have
somebody bring a random bunch of papers
to your house with advertisement you
don't have to do that no one that's good
so you know I gotta happen to a magazine
and subscribe to this podcast if you
want to if you get value out of it
whatever and don't forget about the
warrior keep on guys
I just I got hit I got hit today yeah I
got hit kind of hard
somebody said is the war your kid
podcast dead oh that stings squish that
stinks warrior podcast is not dead but
the warrior kid podcast I need to put
more out so I need a little bit of time
which I'm making but I need to get it
done
so yes warrior kid podcast subscribe to
that I'll get some new ones in there
so Irish Oaks ranch calm is where Aiden
warrior kid up in central Cal has his
own business 13 years old running a
business no big deal mm-hmm that's what
we're kids do
he makes soap from goat milk so that
everyone in the world can stay clean and
no feed about YouTube we have a youtube
channel did you know that yes sir I did
and it's called aqua podcast and it's on
youtube so podcast is not just a podcast
where it's audio only on the video
version you can see us if you want to
know what Jon Stryker Meyer looks like
you can watch this on youtube this is
gonna get a lot of views on YouTube yes
listen to John Stryker Meyer yeah and
hear his stories yeah so check that out
also echo Charles makes what he calls
enhanced videos some people might call
them distracting from the message sir
they might some people like them mmm
they have millions of views some of your
videos that you've made do you know that
oh yeah I did lot of views
well like I said we're like you said
yeah you can call them distractions on
the message which I actually won't even
argue with it thank you but some people
look at it or see it as enhanced it
enhances the message it's kind of like
kind of like you know when you have a
dog and you gotta feed them the
heartworm pills you know where the pills
the heartworm feels good for them it's
good that message is good but sometimes
you gotta put it in the food you know so
like taste good it's like the message
gets to deliver your mind is so hard to
swallow that you have to put like videos
around it is what I'm hearing music
around it yes sometimes we get the
cellos sometimes yes yes hey so that's
the YouTube channel check them out and
then we also got psychological warfare
which is on iTunes Google Play other mp3
platforms and if you want an alarm clock
that's me talking
then you go to psychological warfare and
that's what you get and and you'll see
that you can use it as an alarm clock or
you can use it as an emergency
as an emergency air cover yes fire
support yeah you're like I'm not sure if
I should work out right now press play
yeah on the on the psychological warfare
track that's about not working out you
know and you will get up and you will go
to the gym
you know if you're about to eat some
donuts yes or some chocolate chip
cookies right sure Chips Ahoy whatever
Chips Ahoy going if you find a sleeve of
random Chips Ahoy hanging around
somewhere you know use that term for the
first time when I it was James Nielson
what James Nielson would talk about
eating a sleeve Lee oh yes just get a
fter it James Nielson the world's
toughest accountant agree yes black belt
in jujitsu for a long time well the og
American jiu-jitsu practitioners teaches
hunts on Saturdays here at Victory MMA
and fitness which by the way is our gym
in San Diego California she trained so
you know what's funny about that to
where you know you say oh yeah the
world's toughest accountant right and he
teaches jiu-jitsu too so teaching
jiu-jitsu that's a job like that's a
career like you're a jujitsu instructor
true but he's like he's an accountant
but he just teaches you Jitsu it's not
like an accountant is like some you know
scraping by sword is gay no no no it's
like that's a and there's a few people
like that you know why because teaching
jiu-jitsu is fun yeah and it makes you
better at jujitsu
that's just how it is and the nature of
the game that's on psychological warfare
also you can get it if you want some
visual representation of the path to
keep you there you can go to flipside
canvas dot-com run by my brother Dakota
Meyer he makes art with layers with
layers the layers are free think well
they're not free they come with the cost
of the art right layers included layers
included in your there you go yes we've
designed some of the items there yeah
you know let them know like hey this
would be kind of cool if you want
something just just request Dakota on
Twitter I think is the best place yeah
that's cool flipside campus.com if you
want to get some cool stuff to hang up
in your house back to the psychological
warfare if you use that
being as a playlist psychological
warfare even if it doesn't apply daily
you know you're not eating donuts why a
playlist why you workout even if you're
not eating donuts how you work out which
most of us do not it still like it puts
you in this mindset of like you know
working and reaping results of work yeah
it goes back to the podcast machete
season when they talk about how the
power of the audio into your ear yeah
yeah yeah that's what's happening
psychological warfare yes it's going
right in here you're like you walk you
get done listen that you're not even
thinking about the fact that you're
thinking about the fact yeah you're what
I just said yes you're not thinking
about the fact that you are thinking
about the fact that you know you want
and don't want that you want to get in
the gym that you want to attack your
project oh yeah
that's what's happening well it's 200
percent you also while you're living if
you're lifting at home if we're doing
the lifting at home which I do which you
do which a lot of us do actually people
hit me up show me their home set up
awesome
you should have kettlebells in my
opinion kettlebells is one of them
pretty much the biggest as far as
changes to my workout the most valuable
change that I changed my workout
functionality functionality like the
band's buzzword one time I was doing you
know you gotta introduce you have wrist
control you know and varying levels of
risk control depending on the position
there I was rolling with a guy literally
like he's like trying to release my grip
from his wrist or whatever and like he's
visibly angry cuz he couldn't so I just
sort of sat there and just let him like
do it whatever and I was just technique
because technically he should be able to
get out of that but I've been doing
those kettlebells so my wrist control is
a lot we'll say the effectiveness is a
lot higher nonetheless a regional point
kettlebells this is where I get my
catalyst from on it so you gotta on it
calm slash Jocko there you can get these
kettlebells and they're all the cool
ones too by the way like I always say
Darth Vader my most recent one
stormtrooper kettlebell my second most
recent one and not to mention all the
other primal bells and legend bills that
I have from there also at on it is the
electrolyte mineral
mix that's part of my daily make mix
with chocos discipline like I said the
mineral electrolyte mix water maybe a
little Gator in if I'm feeling a little
feisty and oh and that's how you take a
joint warfare and
drink Gatorade oh hey we got some books
too
we got way of the warrior Kid 3 where
there's a will it's out right now and
for everyone that's got it so far
awesome appreciate it write some reviews
so I know what you think of it that that
is cool if you have worried their work
way of the way your kid 3 where there's
a will that means you should also have
where the word Kid 1 & 2 number two is
called Mark's mission also we got Mikey
in the Dragons best children's book ever
written according to a lot of people a
lot of people a lot of people then tell
me that
I understand tons of people know
seriously check out Mikey the Dragons to
help your kids overcome fear fear of all
cons also got the disappointed cause
freedom Field Manual if you need to know
how to get after it if you want the
audio version of that it's on iTunes
Amazon music in Google Play also we got
extreme ownership and the dichotomy
leadership written by myself and my
brother Leif babban extreme ownership
mm-hmm number one the selling business
book since it got released the whole
time we just got that little stat doing
it skeptical it's a big step yeah yeah
some people tell me that dichotomy of
leadership is better mm-hmm it's a good
combo I'll leave it at that
a tional on front that is my leadership
consultancy what we do is solve problems
through leadership it is me Lafe Babb
and JP Danelle Dave Burke Flint Cochran
Mike's really Mike bimah and Jason
Carter if you need help in your
organization with your leadership which
will help everything that you do in your
business and in your life go to Ashland
front comm for details if you want to
come to the muster you already missed
Chicago it was sold out your next
opportunity is Denver December or sorry
September 19th and 20th that is gonna
sell a help in the December 4th and 5th
and sydney australia if you want to come
to it sign up as quick as you can so
that you can actually go and you don't
get all mad you'll be mad at me
outwardly but deep inside you'll know
you know that you hesitated and you
procrastinate and you just didn't get
your game on and that's why you're not
at the muster so if you want to come to
that check extreme ownership calm EF
online leadership training is not an
inoculation it doesn't take one shot and
now we're good to go you want to follow
up with it and that's what you can do
with EF online or if you can't make it
to the monster for whatever reason go to
EF online online interactive leadership
training check that out
EF online.com and of course we have EF
overwatch if you have a company and you
want to get some good leaders that
understand the principles of extreme
ownership and they're going to apply
them inside your organization go to EF
overwatch comm we will deliver you a
leader from the Special Operations
community or the combat aviation
community that is ready to step into a
role and lead your company to victory
also if you want to hear more about
important things like Hawaii five-o or
other highly intense shows from echo
Charles or if you want to hear about
leadership and war in human nature from
me between the two of us we are on
Twitter we are on Instagram and we are
on
ah echo is a deco Charles and I am at
Jocko willing Ken thanks to all the
veterans out there especially those like
John Stryker Meyer who volunteered and
volunteered and volunteered again to do
the hardest missions in the worst areas
for zero recognition by the way not even
from your own friends and family those
are true heroes and we are forever
indebted to them we are also indebted to
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers Border Patrol Secret Service
all first respondents thanks for keeping
us safe here at home and to everyone
else I know that life can be stressful
but chances are you aren't surrounded by
elephant grass that is 12 feet tall and
burning and closing in on you chances
are you aren't being assaulted by NVA
soldiers chances are you aren't facing
death but at the same time actually you
are facing death we are all facing death
so remember like John Stryker Mayer said
every breath of air is sweet and our
gift is to be alive so go out there and
live then until next time this is echo
and Jocko out